This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. In the enchanted world of Harry Potter, the young wizard discovers a mysterious artifact known as the mirror of Eresed. Carved into its frame is a cryptic inscription. The words make no sense. You have to read them backward to reveal the mirror's true purpose. I show not your face, but your heart's desire. When young Harry looks in the mirror, he sees himself and skiseless.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在哈利·波特那充满魔力的世界里，这位年轻的巫师发现了一件神秘的文物，被称为厄里斯魔镜。镜框上刻着一行晦涩难懂的铭文。这些文字本身毫无意义。你必须倒着读，才能揭示这面镜子的真正用途。我展示的不是你的脸，而是你内心深处的渴望。当年轻的哈利看向镜子时，他看到了自己，
in the loving embrace of a family he never knew. When his friend Ron gazes into the glass, he sees himself finally stepping out of the shadows and outshining others. The vision presented by the mirror of Arisid is alluring, but treacherous. Albus Dumbledore, the wise headmaster of Harry's school, warns that men have wasted away in front of it, even gone mad. The danger lies in the lure of a single perfect image, a vision of the self so captivating
在从未谋面的家人的爱抚中。当他的朋友罗恩凝视镜子时，他看到自己终于走出了阴影，超越了他人。厄里斯魔镜所呈现的幻象虽然诱人，却也充满危险。哈利所在学校睿智的校长阿不思·邓布利多警告说，人们曾在这面镜子前虚度光阴，甚至陷入疯狂。危险在于单一完美形象的诱惑，这种自我幻象如此迷人，
that viewers lose themselves in it. Many of us spend decades searching for a mirror of ERISID. We ask ourselves, Who am I really? What do I really want? These questions are the prelude to the thing we really desire.
以至于观看者会迷失其中。我们许多人花了数十年时间寻找厄里斯魔镜。我们问自己：我到底是谁？我真正想要的是什么？这些问题是我们真正渴望之物的序曲。
Once I know who I am, once I know what I want, surely I will then know what will make me happy. This week on Hidden Brain, why the search for self-knowledge can feel like a mirage, and how to build ourselves a more accurate mirror. From our first days in school, we are taught that the goal of education is to know the world.
一旦我知道我是谁，一旦我知道我想要什么，我肯定就会知道什么能让我快乐。本周的《隐藏的大脑》将探讨：为什么对自我知识的追求有时感觉像海市蜃楼，以及如何为自己打造一面更准确的镜子。从上学的第一天起，我们就被教导教育的目标是认识世界。
We go about mastering the laws of physics, the turning points of revolutions, the syntax of foreign languages. But we're also told there is a deeper requirement for a well-lived life, to know thyself. acquiring self-knowledge is supremely important, but also very difficult. There's no textbook that's been written about you. At the University of Chicago, Eric Oliver has long pondered what it would mean to have such a textbook.
我们致力于掌握物理定律、革命的转折点、外语的语法。但我们也常被告知，过好一生还有一个更深层的要求，那就是“认识你自己”。获取自我知识极其重要，但也非常困难。因为并没有一本关于你的教科书。在芝加哥大学，埃里克·奥利弗长期以来一直在思考，拥有一本这样的教科书意味着什么。
Eric Oliver, welcome to Hidden Brain. It is great to be here. Thank you so much for having me on. Eric, I want to talk about your own journey of self-exploration. When you were in high school, a teacher whom you admired introduced you to the first famous admonition by Socrates to know thyself. How did this advice land with you and your classmates? It landed really well. I was having a very bumpy adolescence, as most adolescence experience, and really just unsure of who I was or where I was going. And I had this wonderful teacher, Mrs. Malone.
埃里克·奥利弗，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。很高兴来到这里。非常感谢邀请我参加。埃里克，我想谈谈你自己的自我探索之旅。你在高中时，一位你敬佩的老师向你介绍了苏格拉底那句著名的劝诫——“认识你自己”。这段建议对你和你的同学们产生了什么影响？影响非常大。当时我正处于一段非常坎坷的青春期，就像大多数青少年经历的那样，真的不确定自己是谁，也不确定要去向何方。我有一位很棒的老师，马龙夫人。
And one day she wrote, know thyself on the blackboard. And she said, distilled in these two words was the collective wisdom of the ancient Greek. You know, those marbleized founders of democracy and poetry. And she said, if we wanted to heed their wisdom, we would need to know the self. And she was such a great teacher. And I took her words to heart. And I thought, yes, this is something I really want to do. So I spent the next three decades of my life trying various ways to get a handle on what's behind this lived experience that I'm going through. And in college, I started reading deeply into psychology and philosophy.
有一天，她在黑板上写下了“认识你自己”。她说，这三个字里浓缩了古希腊人的集体智慧。你知道，那些民主和诗歌的大理石奠基者们。她说，如果我们想遵循他们的智慧，就需要认识自我。她是一位非常伟大的老师。我把她的话记在了心里。我想，是的，这是我真正想做的事情。于是，我花了此后三十年的时间，尝试各种方法来掌控我所经历的这种生活体验背后的东西。在大学里，我开始深入研读心理学和哲学。
After college, I moved to Northern California, and I started doing yoga and practicing meditation. I experimented with everything from psychedelics to, you know, hiking naked in the wilderness to backpacking through Asia. I tried to seek out gurus and priests and Turkish rugs sellers who often have a surprising amount of knowledge about. spiritual matters, I was basically trying to do everything to click every box on the spiritual seekers bucket list. And it was a very enthusiastic and a very sincere desire to get at what was behind this experience of being. I understand that at one point you felt that finding the right person to love would be a way of discovering who you really were. Well, I think this was a big part of my feeling of discontentment was a lot of my own psychological instability at the time,
大学毕业后，我搬到了北加州，开始练习瑜伽和冥想。我尝试了一切，从迷幻药到在荒野中裸体徒步，再到背包游历亚洲。我试图寻找大师、牧师和土耳其地毯商，他们往往对精神事务有着惊人的了解。我基本上是在尝试做每一件事，试图勾选精神追求者清单上的每一个选项。这是一种非常热切且真诚的渴望，想要探究这种存在体验背后的真相。我了解到，在某个阶段，你曾觉得找到合适的人去爱，将是发现真实自我的一种方式。嗯，我想这很大程度上源于我当时心理上的不稳定，
which probably traced back to my own bumpy family life. And I had this very romantic idea that there was some perfect person out there who, if I could just meet that person, they would complete me. They would fulfill all of my needs and all of my longings. And they would provide me with that sense of psychological stability that would just anchor me. And if that was a big part of knowing myself and figuring this out, was, oh, finding that right person. And what ended up happening, ironically, was that I had a series of failed relationships and bumpy relationships.
这可能追溯到我坎坷的家庭生活。我当时有一种非常浪漫的想法，认为世界上存在一个完美的人，如果我能遇见那个人，他们就会使我完整。他们会满足我所有的需求和渴望。他们会给我那种能让我安定的心理稳定感。如果说认识自我和弄清楚这一切有一大部分原因，那就是“找到那个对的人”。而讽刺的是，最终发生的事情是，我经历了一系列失败且坎坷的关系。
And I realized if I was going to have a successful relationship, I actually needed to figure myself out first because in a lot of ways, I was my own worst obstacle for getting the love I so desperately wanted. I understand that in some of these relationships, you actually felt like there were parts of you that were at odds with other parts of you as you pursued these relationships. Well, yes, there was that part of me that was longing for connection and attachment and love and that feeling of just great effervescence.
我意识到，如果我想要一段成功的关系，我实际上需要先弄清楚我自己，因为在很多方面，我正是自己获得梦寐以求的爱情的最大障碍。我了解到，在其中一些关系中，当你追求这些关系时，你实际上感觉到自己内心有部分与另一部分相冲突。嗯，是的，我内心有一部分渴望联系、依恋、爱，以及那种伟大的活力感。
And yet oftentimes, as soon as I started, started getting close to someone and their full humanity started getting revealed to me, I would freak out. And I would find other parts of me pulling back in fear and finding myself being avoidant and saying, oh, this is a real human being who I'm in relationship with. This isn't the magic elixir. And something must be wrong because surely, you know, it wouldn't be bumpy if it was right. I understand it wasn't just in your love life that you felt. like you got in your own way. You were an ambitious and driven young person, but when you achieved what you thought yourself wanted a prestigious job as a university professor, it turned
然而，很多时候，当我开始与某人亲近，而他们完整的人性开始向我展现时，我就会惊慌失措。我会发现自己内心的其他部分在恐惧中退缩，变得回避，并说：“哦，这是一个真实的人，我正在与他建立关系。这不是什么魔法灵药。”而且肯定有什么地方不对劲，因为如果它是对的，肯定不会这么坎坷。我了解到，不仅在你的爱情生活中，你觉得自己在阻碍自己。你是一个雄心勃勃、干劲十足的年轻人，但当你实现了自己认为想要的目标——一份著名的大学教授工作时，结果却
out to not be what it was cracked up to be? Yeah, I struggled through grad school, like all graduate students. You know, there was a lot of work, a very long time for a very uncertain outcome, and I got my first job at Princeton. And that shocked me as much as all those people around me, I think. And I get to Princeton and I'm like, this is as far as an academic goes, this is as good as it gets. And I get there and it's this wonderful university and I have these amazing students. And I get there and my life kind of falls apart. A long-term relationship I had been in. I ended very abruptly.
发现它并非如你所想的那样？是的，我和所有研究生一样，在研究生院挣扎。你知道，那是大量的工作，漫长的时间，却有着非常不确定的结果。我得到了普林斯顿的第一份工作。这让我和周围的人一样感到震惊。我到了普林斯顿，心想：作为一名学者，这已经是顶峰了，这已经是最好的了。我到了那里，那是一所很棒的大学，我有很棒的学生。但我到了那里，我的生活却崩溃了。我的一段长期关系突然结束了。
I suddenly found myself really depressed living alone in central New Jersey. I barely knew anyone. And all of this pain that had come from kind of the earlier stages of my life really welled up in me. And I could barely function in front of my classes. I wasn't eating. I wasn't sleeping. And I have to say that was probably for me one of the kind of low points of my life. And there was this irony of like, oh my God, I got everything that I worked for and life feels kind of terrible. I understand that it got bad enough that you briefly consider taking a rather drastic step. Tell me what happened in that moment, Derek. Well, I was standing
我突然发现自己非常抑郁，独自住在新泽西州中部。我几乎不认识任何人。所有来自我早年生活的痛苦都涌上心头。我在课堂上几乎无法正常工作。我不吃不喝。我必须说，那可能是我人生中的低谷之一。这真是讽刺，我得到了我为之奋斗的一切，但生活却感觉如此糟糕。我了解到情况变得很糟，以至于你曾短暂地考虑采取一个相当极端的步骤。告诉我那一刻发生了什么，埃里克。嗯，我当时正站在
on the sidewalk of a very, very busy street in New Jersey, and I'm standing there right on the curb, and I was just carrying around so much pain. And it occurred to me that, oh, all this pain would go away if I just stepped in front of this speeding truck that was coming towards me. And then that impulse, I've never had an impulse like that before, scared the daylights out of me. Because, A, it was this kind of very strong self-destructive impulse. And B, you know, getting run over by a garbage truck in central New Jersey seemed a truly humiliating way to go. So it was at that moment that I said, okay, I need to fix things. And that's really when I started pursuing therapy in great detail. I'm wondering as you went through these decades trying to find yourself and finding yourself
新泽西州一条非常非常繁忙的街道的人行道上，我就站在路边，我背负着太多的痛苦。我突然想到，如果我直接走到那辆向我冲来的超速卡车前面，所有的痛苦都会消失。那种冲动——我以前从未有过那样的冲动——把我吓坏了。因为，第一，这是一种非常强烈的自我毁灭冲动；第二，你知道，在新泽西州中部被垃圾车撞死，似乎是一种极其屈辱的死法。所以就在那一刻，我说：“好吧，我需要解决这些问题。”那才是我真正开始深入寻求心理治疗的时候。我想知道，当你花了数十年时间试图寻找自我却发现自己
coming up short. What did you tell yourself? Did you just say, I'm looking at the wrong place, or I haven't looked hard enough? Well, I think in my 20s, like a lot of people, I was chasing this gold star illusion. I thought, well, whatever dissatisfaction I'm having now, you know, if I could just get that next gold star. So if I could just finish my PhD, if I could just get that great job, if I could just, you know, buy the perfect house, all of these things that we think are so important, And then all of these problems and discontentment that I'm feeling will somehow another just solve themselves and go away. And what I was finding was just the opposite. The more I was going further down the path of this gold star trajectory, the worse I seemed to be doing.
一无所获时，你对自己说了什么？你只是说“我找错地方了”，还是“我找得不够努力”？嗯，我想在我20多岁时，像许多人一样，我在追逐这种“金星”幻觉。我想，无论我现在有什么不满，如果我能得到下一个“金星”——如果我能拿到博士学位，如果我能得到那份好工作，如果我能买到完美的房子——所有这些我们认为非常重要的事情，那么我所感受到的所有问题和不满都会以某种方式自行解决并消失。但我发现的恰恰相反。我在“金星”轨迹上走得越远，我的情况似乎就越糟。
Eric spent years trying to find himself in order to understand how to become happy and fulfilled. Eventually, he came to realize that the search was misguided. When we come back, the surprising reason Eric couldn't find the self he was looking for. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. For two decades, Eric Oliver has taught a popular course at the University of Chicago about the search for self-knowledge. After years searching for his own true self, Eric came to realize why the quest had been unproductive.
埃里克花了多年时间试图寻找自我，以了解如何变得快乐和满足。最终，他意识到这种寻找是误入歧途的。稍后回来，我们将探讨埃里克无法找到他所寻找的自我的惊人原因。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。二十年来，埃里克·奥利弗一直在芝加哥大学教授一门关于寻找自我知识的热门课程。在寻找了自己真实自我多年后，埃里克意识到为什么这种追求是徒劳的。
He didn't have a single unitary core to his being. Eric's high school English teacher had instructed him to follow the ancient command to know thyself. But what if there is no single self to know? Eric, you say that in fact the Greeks themselves did not mean know thyself when they told us know thyself. What did they mean? They really meant something more like know thy place. And for most of human history, these were probably the best three words you could live by. Most of our ancestors lived in very small tribes, tightly bound by custom and tradition.
他的存在并没有一个单一的、统一的核心。埃里克的英语老师曾教导他遵循古老的命令“认识你自己”。但如果根本没有一个单一的自我去认识呢？埃里克，你说事实上希腊人自己在说“认识你自己”时，指的并不是我们现在理解的意思。他们指的是什么？他们真正想表达的更像是“认清你的位置”。在人类历史的大部分时间里，这可能是你所能遵循的最好的三个字。我们的大多数祖先生活在非常小的部落中，被习俗和传统紧密束缚。
They didn't worry about what made them happy or how they would find true love or what their purpose in life would be because all of those things were arranged for them. Who they were, who they should love, what they should do. All of those things were prescribed by custom and tradition. And so the best thing they could do was simply to go along with that custom tradition because in return, the tribe would protect them and nurture them and keep them going. It was only around 300 years ago with the birth of the Enlightenment, the rise of market capitalism, the rise of liberalism and liberal democracy where we prioritize individual rights and liberties, that this modern notion of self, this individualized, autonomous seeking one's own purpose in life's self, really came to displace that old meaning of know thyself. I'm wondering if there was a moment when you realized that the search for your one true self
他们不担心什么能让他们快乐，或者如何找到真爱，或者他们的人生目标是什么，因为所有这些事情都已经为他们安排好了。他们是谁，他们应该爱谁，他们应该做什么，所有这些都由习俗和传统规定好了。所以他们能做的最好的事情就是简单地遵循这些习俗和传统，因为作为回报，部落会保护他们、培养他们并让他们生存下去。直到大约300年前，随着启蒙运动的诞生、市场资本主义的兴起、自由主义和自由民主制的兴起，我们开始优先考虑个人权利和自由，这种现代的自我概念——这种个体化的、自主的、寻求自身人生目标的自我——才真正取代了“认识你自己”的旧含义。我想知道，是否有那么一刻，你意识到对单一真实自我的寻找
was in fact a problematic search, that there were many selves inside you. Can you think of a moment when that became apparent to you, Eric? I think it probably hit me first when I went on my first long meditation retreat. and so I went on this silent 10-day meditation retreat and at one point I was thinking during the retreat it's like oh I want to meditate because I want to be a better person and if I could just meditate somehow another maybe that will make be a better person and all my problems could go away and I realized that there was no person really that was there
实际上是一个有问题的问题，你内心有许多个自我。你能想到那一刻吗，埃里克？我想这可能是在我第一次参加长期冥想静修时首先击中我的。我参加了一个为期10天的静默冥想静修。在静修期间，我心想：“哦，我想冥想，因为我想成为一个更好的人，如果我能冥想，也许那会让我成为一个更好的人，我所有的问题都会消失。”但我意识到，那里并没有一个真正的“人”存在，
because when I quieted my mind down and I was just there in my own conscious experience there was no single stable solitary thing there. It was more like a diffuse cloud of energy that was constantly in flux. And I realized that, oh, these thoughts that I typically identify with, this ego, this feeling of Eric, professor, guy, American, etc., all those were just kind of ephemeral flotsam
因为当我让心静下来，仅仅处于我自己的意识体验中时，那里并没有一个单一、稳定、孤独的东西。它更像是一团不断流动的弥散能量云。我意识到，我通常认同的那些想法——这个自我，这种“埃里克、教授、家伙、美国人”的感觉等等——都只是某种短暂的漂浮物，
kind of on the surface of this much bigger roiling stew of energy that was in a lot of ways very ineffable. You've done a lot of thinking about the different ways in which we can understand how the self is divided. You've thought a lot about Charles Darwin, who introduced the radical notion that humans are animals driven by, you know, survival-based instincts. Why would Darwin's idea challenge the notion of a single unitary self, Eric? Well, once we start looking at our evolutionary lineage, we come to some kind of disturbing, qualities about ourselves. For one, everything that is alive on this planet traces back to one common ancestor that lived about 3.7 billion years ago, and scientists have playfully named this creature
漂浮在这个更大、更混乱的能量炖锅表面，在很多方面是非常难以言表的。你对我们理解自我如何分裂的不同方式做了很多思考。你对查尔斯·达尔文思考良多，他引入了一个激进的概念，即人类是受生存本能驱动的动物。为什么达尔文的观点会挑战单一统一自我的概念呢，埃里克？嗯，一旦我们开始审视我们的进化谱系，我们就会发现关于我们自己的一些令人不安的特质。首先，这个星球上所有活着的东西都可以追溯到大约37亿年前生活的一个共同祖先，科学家们戏称这个生物为
Luca. And Luca had the seeds of genes that are in every little living thing today. And so one thing that means is that in a lot of ways, everything that we see that's around us are cousins to us. were all part of the same underlying life force that started burning in this creature that lived 3.7 billion years ago. And everything that we are is in a lot of ways an elaboration on these self-processes that started with Luca. And it gets even more complicated because once you start looking at your cellular structure, you begin to realize there is no single being there.
“卢卡”（LUCA）。卢卡拥有今天每一个微小生物体内基因的种子。这意味着，在很多方面，我们周围看到的一切都是我们的表亲。我们都是同一个潜在生命力的一部分，这种生命力始于37亿年前生活在这个生物体内的火花。我们所拥有的一切，在很多方面都是对始于卢卡的这些自我过程的阐述。而且情况变得更加复杂，因为一旦你开始观察你的细胞结构，你就会开始意识到那里并没有一个单一的生命存在。
For example, each of our cells contain mitochondria. And mitochondria are interesting because they have an intelligent, entirely different DNA than the DNA that programs for us. And so in a lot of ways, we're an amalgamation of two different species at the cellular level. And then, of course, we're multicellular, so we're all of these cells coming together and carrying around also a microbiome with thousands of other species kind of living in and amongst us. And even this sense of perception and consciousness that we have is really the orchestration of all of these cells coming together. And once you begin to appreciate that that's your physical reality,
例如，我们的每个细胞都含有线粒体。线粒体很有趣，因为它们拥有与我们自身基因组完全不同的智能DNA。所以，在很多方面，我们在细胞层面是两个不同物种的结合体。当然，我们是多细胞生物，所以我们是所有这些细胞聚集在一起，同时还携带了一个微生物组，里面有成千上万的其他物种生活在我们体内和周围。甚至我们拥有的这种感知和意识，实际上也是所有这些细胞聚集在一起的协调结果。一旦你开始意识到这就是你的物理现实，
that that's what's behind this experience of being, you realize there's not really a single solitary eye there. It's much more of a we. It's also the case that I think when we think about ourselves, all of us have had the experience of, you know, wanting to be kind and good people, but then suddenly finding ourselves acting selfishly. We might want to be patient people, but then we find ourselves, losing our temper. So it's almost as if we have, you know, these different cells inside us that have their own agendas. It's exactly right. And one way to think about that is that your self is not a solitary thing. It's a process or more accurately a set of processes. And these processes sometimes work together, but sometimes they work at cross purposes. So you have a cellular
这就是这种存在体验背后的真相，你就会意识到那里并没有一个单一、孤独的“我”。它更像是一个“我们”。同样的情况是，我认为当我们思考自己时，我们所有人都经历过想要成为善良、优秀的人，但随后却发现自己表现得很自私。我们可能想成为有耐心的人，但随后却发现自己失去了耐心。所以这几乎就像我们内心有不同的细胞，它们有自己的议程。完全正确。思考这个问题的一种方式是，你的自我不是一个孤独的东西。它是一个过程，或者更准确地说，是一组过程。这些过程有时协同工作，有时却背道而驰。所以你有一个细胞
self, which is your, your cell's metabolizing energy. You have an animal cell. You have an animal cell. that's there making maps of reality and making predictions about what it thinks is going to happen next. Of course, we humans have language. So we have this linguistic self where we've created culture
自我，也就是你细胞代谢能量的过程。你有一个动物自我，
and laws and morals and identities. And those are a big part of our self processes as well. And so a lot of these oftentimes are in conflict with one another. Like what our animal self is either predicting or wanting or desiring may be very, very strongly at odds
在那里绘制现实地图，并对它认为接下来会发生什么做出预测。当然，我们人类有语言。所以我们有一个语言自我，我们创造了文化、法律、道德和身份。这些也是我们自我过程的重要组成部分。因此，其中许多往往是相互冲突的。比如我们的动物自我所预测、想要或渴望的东西，可能与我们的语言自我告诉我们在那一刻需要做的事情非常、非常强烈地冲突。
with what our linguistic self tells us we need to be doing at that moment. You also talk about the tension between our higher cognitive faculties and some of our survival-based instincts and how in some ways these tensions are compounded by modern life. Talk about the relationship we might have with food and how that's shaped both by ancient cues, but also ancient cues that are out of step with the modern world in which we live. Right. So I have a real weakness.
你还谈到了我们更高认知能力与我们一些基于生存的本能之间的紧张关系，以及在某些方面，这些紧张关系是如何被现代生活所加剧的。谈谈我们可能与食物之间的关系，以及它是如何既被古老的线索所塑造，又被与我们所处的现代世界脱节的古老线索所塑造的。好的。我有一个真正的弱点。
I feel about ice cream the way that Frederick the Great felt about tall Prussian soldiers. And I just, sugar in particular, it just has me wrapped around its little crystalline finger. And I know sugar is bad for me. I want to be healthy. I see how it jangles my mood. But boy, I just crave it all the time. I just love it, especially late at night. and that's when the ice cream cravings really hit like a freight train.
我对冰淇淋的感觉就像腓特烈大帝对高个子普鲁士士兵的感觉一样。糖分尤其让我无法抗拒。我知道糖对我不好。我想保持健康。我看到它如何扰乱我的情绪。但天哪，我一直渴望它。我就是喜欢它，尤其是在深夜。那时冰淇淋的渴望就像货运列车一样袭来。
And this is a lot of conflict for me. Like here I am in this experience of me, yet I'm torn between this just deep craving for ice cream and a mind that knows that, you know, slim waste and chubby hubby just are not things that go together. And so the big part of a lot of our self-processes are about negotiating these conflicts. And that craving for ice cream is situated
这对我来说有很多冲突。我处于这种“我”的体验中，但我却在对冰淇淋的深切渴望与一个知道“苗条腰身”和“肥胖”是不可能共存的头脑之间挣扎。所以我们许多自我过程的很大一部分是关于协商这些冲突的。而对冰淇淋的渴望位于
in some deep biological signals in our brains about what sugar rewards for us. When we consume sugar, it's signaling to our brain, hey, this is a lot of calories. This is a great thing for us to eat. And if we were in the wild, we would just be all over it. So in a way, refined sugar hijacks our brains. And then we live in a consumeristic culture
我们大脑中关于糖分如何奖励我们的一些深层生物信号中。当我们摄入糖分时，它会向我们的大脑发出信号：“嘿，这是大量的热量。这是我们吃的好东西。”如果我们身处野外，我们肯定会大快朵颐。所以从某种意义上说，精制糖劫持了我们的大脑。然后我们生活在一个消费主义文化中，
where we're just flooded in all of these things that hijack our neural systems. We can see this in our food. We can see this with the internet, which triggers all of these dopamine releases and keeps us coming back for more and more and more. We can see it in just all the consumeristic pleasures that are offered to us in our modern capitalist society. And so all of these things are really taking our animal processes and just hijacking them and pulling them out of whack. And so no wonder we often feel so torn apart and pulled in so many different directions. Do you find your feet carrying you to the ice cream store, even when your brain is telling you,
我们被所有这些劫持我们神经系统的东西所淹没。我们可以在食物中看到这一点。我们可以在互联网上看到这一点，它触发了所有这些多巴胺释放，让我们不断回来寻求更多。我们可以在现代资本主义社会提供给我们的所有消费主义快乐中看到这一点。所以所有这些东西实际上都在劫持我们的动物过程，并使它们失去平衡。难怪我们经常感到如此分裂，被拉向这么多不同的方向。你是否发现你的双脚把你带到了冰淇淋店，即使你的大脑在告诉你，
turn around and walk away? Oh, sure. I'm like, honey, got to walk the dog again. My dog knows our neighborhood bodega very, very well. Another reason we find ourselves divided against ourselves is that most of us tend to to identify with our conscious minds as if that is the whole of who we are, when in fact we are powerfully driven by forces that are outside of our conscious awareness. Talk about this idea that even at a psychological level, it's not like there's one of us. Right. And we could
“转身走开”？哦，当然。我会说：“亲爱的，得再去遛狗了。”我的狗非常非常熟悉我们社区的杂货店。我们发现自己与自己分裂的另一个原因是，我们大多数人倾向于认同我们的意识思维，仿佛那就是我们的全部，而事实上，我们被意识之外的力量强有力地驱动着。谈谈这个观点，即使在心理层面，也不是只有一个“我们”。是的，我们可以
see this in what I would describe as sort of this fourth layer of self, which I would call the egoistic self. So all of us have these egos. And egos are really just these suite of neural processes, that are there to help us get what we want from other people. And our egos defend our entitlements and our rights, but they also are there to keep us from saying awkward things or things that might later get us in trouble. So we have these suite of ego mechanisms, and they get wrapped up in our identities and our aspirations.
在所谓的“第四层自我”中看到这一点，我称之为“自我主义自我”（egoistic self）。所以我们所有人都有这些自我。自我实际上只是一套神经过程，旨在帮助我们从他人那里获得我们想要的东西。我们的自我捍卫我们的权利和资格，但它们也存在于防止我们说出尴尬的话或以后可能给我们带来麻烦的话。所以我们有这些自我机制，它们被包裹在我们的身份和抱负中。
We can see this oftentimes when we're just daydreaming and oftentimes we drift into thinking, oh, I shouldn't have done that before. That was such a terrible mistake. or, oh, I can't wait for this to happen and dreaming about the future. And our egos always pull us oftentimes in these very uncomfortable directions here. And we typically then think that that's the totality of ourselves. We oftentimes just get so compressed by these ego processes.
我们经常在白日梦时看到这一点，我们经常陷入思考：“哦，我之前不该那样做。那真是个可怕的错误。”或者“哦，我迫不及待地想让这件事发生”，并梦想着未来。我们的自我总是把我们拉向这些非常不舒服的方向。然后我们通常认为这就是我们自我的全部。我们经常被这些自我过程压缩得太厉害了。
They typically dominate our field of consciousness that we get cut off from all the other things that are going on that are animating us. So, you know, we're so busy thinking about ourselves. we don't really taste the food that we're shoveling into our mouths, or we don't notice the beauty of nature around us, or just the smaller ways of connecting with another person. And these are really the challenges of self-knowledge because a big part of wanting to know ourselves
它们通常主宰了我们的意识领域，以至于我们与正在发生、正在激励我们的所有其他事情隔绝了。所以，你知道，我们太忙于思考自己了，我们并没有真正品尝我们塞进嘴里的食物，或者我们没有注意到周围自然的美，或者仅仅是与另一个人联系的小方式。这些确实是自我知识的挑战，因为想要认识自己的很大一部分
is getting to decompress from these ego processes, so they don't loom so large and just dominate our conscious attention the way they typically do. Talk a moment about this idea that even, as we are going about our lives, you know, trying to shape our lives and doing things consciously, we're often influenced by a host of things that lie outside of our conscious awareness. I mean, in some ways, this is at the heart of, you know, everything that we have done that hidden brain these last many years, which is this idea that there are biases inside
是学会从这些自我过程中解压，这样它们就不会显得那么庞大，也不会像通常那样主宰我们的意识注意力。谈谈这个观点，即使当我们过着我们的生活，试图有意识地塑造我们的生活并做事情时，我们经常受到许多位于我们意识之外的事物的支配。我的意思是，在某种程度上，这是我们这些年来在《隐藏的大脑》中所做的一切的核心，即存在着偏见
us that are operating outside of our awareness. Yes, psychologists have a really eloquent way of describing this, and they call this System 1 and System 2 thinking. So, System 1 thinking is our fast, intuitive, reflexive types of thinking. It's the kind of information processing that our brains do without really thinking at all. It's much more reflexive and habitual. It's how I know just to walk to work without even thinking about where I'm going, for example. And that typically orientes us through a lot of the day, and we're not even aware of it. It's just kind of on autopilot.
在我们内部，在我们的意识之外运作。是的，心理学家有一种非常雄辩的方式来描述这一点，他们称之为“系统1”和“系统2”思维。所以，系统1思维是我们快速、直觉、反射性的思维方式。这是我们大脑在不经思考的情况下进行的信息处理。它更具反射性和习惯性。例如，我知道如何走路去上班，甚至不需要思考我要去哪里。这通常引导我们度过一天的大部分时间，我们甚至没有意识到这一点。它就像处于自动驾驶状态。
What we're typically aware of is what psychologists call System 2 thinking. And this is when we encounter something that requires a decision, where we encounter some anomalous information or something that's in conflict. So, for example, when I'm trying to resist ice cream, but I find myself walking to the bodega and that conflict going on. That's my system two thinking in full flower there. And when we think of this concept, for example, of free will, what it really is is system two thinking. Eric, you're a political scientist, and I understand that you've seen evidence in your own field that we have different political selves inside of us. Talk about this idea for a minute. What we can see in a lot of our politics is an intuitive kind of politics where people say,
我们通常意识到的是心理学家所说的“系统2”思维。这是当我们遇到需要决策的事情，或者遇到一些异常信息或冲突的事情时。例如，当我试图抵制冰淇淋，却发现自己正走向杂货店，那种冲突正在发生。那就是我的系统2思维在全面运作。当我们思考“自由意志”这个概念时，它实际上就是系统2思维。埃里克，你是一位政治学家，我了解到你在自己的领域中看到了证据，表明我们内心有不同的政治自我。谈谈这个观点。在我们许多政治活动中，我们可以看到一种直觉性的政治，人们说：
oh, just don't trust my thinking. I just go with my gut. Well, the problem is, is think about what our gut tells us. And I try to get at the sense of how much people rely on their intuitions with a series of survey questions. For example, I would ask somebody, would you rather stab a photograph of your family five times with a sharp knife or stick your hand in a bowl of cockroaches? And you would think, oh, well, the rational brain would be like, why would I want to stick my hand in a bowl of cockroaches? But about 50% of people say, no, I'd rather do that than stab a photograph of my family with a knife, even though that's just a symbolic cost. But because it resonates so much with their intuitions, it seems real to them. And I think that's what a lot of
“哦，别相信我的思考。我只是跟着直觉走。”嗯，问题是，想想我们的直觉告诉我们什么。我试图通过一系列调查问题来了解人们在多大程度上依赖他们的直觉。例如，我会问某人：“你宁愿用锋利的刀刺你的家庭照片五次，还是把手伸进一碗蟑螂里？”你会想，哦，理性的头脑会想：“我为什么要伸手进一碗蟑螂里？”但大约50%的人说：“不，我宁愿那样做，也不愿用刀刺我的家庭照片”，即使那只是象征性的代价。但因为它与他们的直觉产生了强烈的共鸣，这在他们看来是真实的。我认为这就是我们今天许多
our politics today are, are we have various kinds of political messages out there that really bypass or circumvent our rational minds and really trigger our intuitions to get us to think about things in ways that are oftentimes very contrary to the rationalistic demands of living in a democracy. So when you think about recent events in politics, I mean, I think many people will say, well, I am thinking about them rationally. I am thinking about them deliberately. It's just the other side that's not being rational and deliberate. How would you respond to that, Eric? Well, I pride myself. I'm a university professor. So I pride myself on being a very rationalistic person. But even still, like I will see some injustice online and immediately get in real. And rather than seeing the complexity of the circumstances, I will immediately say, those people are bad. Those are the ones who should be targeted. You know, that's my first, you know, those people are evil. They're horrible. How could they be doing that? And that's that intuitive sense, like wanting to scapegoat somebody, wanting to come to a very quick and easy conclusion. And a lot of this goes back to what our animal brains are trying to do. Remember, our animal brains are prediction machine. They're taking in lots and lots of information from the world, and they're trying to map reality and make predictions about what they think is going to happen next. And our animal brains love certainty, because certainty is how we can make quick and efficient decisions and predictions.
政治的样子，我们有各种各样的政治信息，它们真正绕过了我们的理性头脑，真正触发了我们的直觉，让我们以往往与民主生活中的理性要求背道而驰的方式思考问题。所以当你想到最近的政治事件时，我的意思是，我想许多人会说：“我是在理性地思考它们。我是在审慎地思考它们。只是另一方没有理性、没有审慎。”你会如何回应，埃里克？嗯，我以自己为荣。我是一名大学教授。所以我以自己是一个非常理性的人而自豪。但即便如此，我会在网上看到一些不公正的事情，并立即感到愤怒。与其看到情况的复杂性，我会立即说：“那些人是坏人。那些人应该成为目标。”你知道，这是我的第一反应，“那些人是邪恶的。他们太可怕了。他们怎么能那样做？”这就是那种直觉感，想要找替罪羊，想要得出一个非常快速和简单的结论。而这很多都回到了我们的动物大脑试图做的事情。记住，我们的动物大脑是预测机器。它们从世界中获取大量信息，试图绘制现实地图，并对它们认为接下来会发生什么做出预测。我们的动物大脑喜欢确定性，因为确定性是我们做出快速高效决策和预测的方式。
And so we will glom on to anything that gives us a taste of certainty, because if we don't have certainty, we oftentimes experience a lot of anxiety. And anxiety is a very uncomfortable place to live in. So rather than coexist with the anxiety of uncertainty, we will immediately glom on to a scapegoat or some quick or easy explanation for something, oftentimes at the expense of the more complicated reality underneath it. And of course, from the point of view of, you know, know thyself, both these sides of us are ourselves. I mean, the side of us that wants to draw the quick intuitive conclusion is us, and the side that wants to be reasoned and rational is also us. That's right. And part of our task if we want to live better,
所以我们会抓住任何给我们带来确定性味道的东西，因为如果我们没有确定性，我们往往会经历很多焦虑。而焦虑是一个非常不舒服的居住地。所以与其与不确定性的焦虑共存，我们宁愿立即抓住一个替罪羊或某种快速简单的解释，往往是以牺牲其下更复杂的现实为代价。当然，从“认识你自己”的角度来看，我们这两面都是我们自己。我的意思是，想要得出快速直觉结论的那一面是我们，想要理性、合理的那一面也是我们。完全正确。如果我们想过得更好，我们任务的一部分，
and I think this is what Mrs. Malone, my English teacher, was actually trying to communicate to us, is becoming aware of these different self-processes and not letting one or the other necessarily dominate us so much, but listening to them. and recognizing them and seeing what they're up to. Another reason we are divided against ourselves is that we adopt different personas
我认为这正是我的英语老师马龙夫人试图传达给我们的，那就是意识到这些不同的自我过程，不让其中一个必然主宰我们太多，而是倾听它们，
depending on the setting and the people we are with. This notion of a psychological persona was first introduced by Carl Young. What did he mean by this term, Eric? So I was talking earlier about the egoistic self. It's the part of our psychology that is trying to make its way and help us make our way
识别它们，看看它们在做什么。我们与自己分裂的另一个原因是，我们根据环境和与我们在一起的人采用不同的角色（persona）。这种心理角色概念最早由卡尔·荣格提出。埃里克，他这个术语是什么意思？所以我之前谈到了“自我主义自我”。它是我们心理中试图开辟道路并帮助我们开辟道路的部分，
through our social worlds. And here's the funny thing about the egoistic self. It doesn't lend itself to science that well, a scientific inquiry that well. We don't know where in the brain the ego really resides. We don't know about all its constituent parts. And funnily enough, the way we know about this egoistic self is through our stories.
通过我们的社会世界。关于自我主义自我，有趣的事情是：它并不太适合科学，不太适合科学探究。我们不知道自我真正驻留在大脑的哪个位置。我们不知道它的所有组成部分。有趣的是，我们了解这个自我主义自我的方式是通过我们的故事。
So if you think about when you go to therapy, for example, what do you do? You tell your therapist your stories. the stories of your day, the stories of your life. And you interpret those stories. And that's how you begin to dissect and understand this egoistic self. Well, then the big question is, is, okay, we have these stories. How should we interpret them?
所以如果你想想当你去接受心理治疗时，例如，你做什么？你告诉你的治疗师你的故事。你一天的故事，你人生的故事。然后你解释这些故事。这就是你开始剖析和理解这个自我主义自我的方式。那么大问题是：好的，我们有了这些故事。我们应该如何解释它们？
And this is where someone like Carl Jung could be very useful. Now, Carl Jung was not really a scientist. He was much more of a mystic, but he offers us some really interesting conceptual tools for interpreting our own stories. And one of his great insights was this idea that we have personae. And the word personae comes from Latin origins, and it originally meant the masks that Etruscan mimes used to wear in early dramas.
这就是像卡尔·荣格这样的人可以非常有用的地方。卡尔·荣格并不是真正的科学家。他更像是一个神秘主义者，但他为我们解释自己的故事提供了一些非常有趣的工具。他伟大的见解之一就是我们拥有“角色”（personae）的想法。这个词源于拉丁语，最初指的是伊特鲁里亚哑剧演员在早期戏剧中佩戴的面具。
And they're literally the mask that we present ourselves to the world around us. And all of us have a wide collection of these personae, and we tend to take one on, put one on or take one off, depending on whatever circumstance that we're in. So when I'm in front of my students, I have the persona of the authoritative professor, because they seem to like that. When I'm with my friends, I'm the more jovial clown. With my children, I try to be the nurturing father. And these are all parts of myself, but they don't necessarily define myself in its totality because I'm constantly switching them.
它们字面上就是我们向周围世界展示自己的面具。我们所有人都有大量的这些角色，我们倾向于根据我们所处的任何环境，戴上一个或摘下一个。所以当我在学生面前时，我有权威教授的角色，因为他们似乎喜欢那样。当我和朋友在一起时，我是更风趣的小丑。和我的孩子们在一起时，我努力成为慈爱的父亲。这些都是我自我的部分，但它们并不一定定义了我的全部自我，因为我一直在切换它们。
What works in one moment is not necessarily going to work in another moment. So acting the jovial clown won't work at a serious academic conference. And so part of knowing ourselves is both recognizing when we're in our different personas, but also recognizing that our persona are not us. The mask that I'm wearing at any given moment is not me. It's just a vehicle, a convenience for negotiating with this period of time. And the more that I identify or invest strongly in that one persona, I think the more distorted my experience of being is going to become. I understand that you grew up in Texas and found yourself in New England at one point.
在一个时刻有效的方法在另一个时刻不一定有效。所以扮演风趣的小丑在严肃的学术会议上是行不通的。因此，认识自己的一部分既是识别我们处于不同的角色中，也是认识到我们的角色不是我们。我在任何特定时刻戴的面具不是我。它只是一个工具，一个与这段时间进行协商的便利手段。我认为，我越是认同或强烈投入到那个单一的角色中，我对存在的体验就会变得越扭曲。我了解到你在德克萨斯州长大，后来发现自己身处新英格兰。
Talk about the masks you had to wear and the masks you had to take off. Well, one of my favorite stories about this is I grew up in Texas. And even though I grew up in Houston, I never felt a strong identity of Texan. Like I never had a cowboy hat. I never had, you know, cowboy boots. I never drove a truck or any of that stuff. And I got to go to college in New England. And I thought, oh, wow, I'm going to go to New England.
谈谈你必须戴上的面具和你必须摘下的面具。嗯，关于这个我最喜欢的故事之一是我在德克萨斯州长大。尽管我在休斯顿长大，但我从未感到强烈的德克萨斯人身份。我从来没有牛仔帽。我从来没有牛仔靴。我从来没有开过卡车或类似的东西。我去了新英格兰上大学。我想：“哦，哇，我要去新英格兰了。”
And I'm going to, you know, find all these people who have, you know, are intellectual and cultural and all of these values that I have. And I get there. And the funny thing is, is the one thing that people found most interesting about me was that I was from Texas. And at the time, this is especially girls. And so, ironically, I found myself playing up my Texanness. And like when I went home for that first winter break, and my sister asked me what I wanted for Christmas, I said, how about some cowboy boots?
“我要去寻找所有那些知识分子、有文化、拥有我所拥有的所有价值观的人。”我到了那里。有趣的是，人们觉得我最有趣的一点是我来自德克萨斯州。当时，尤其是女孩们。所以，讽刺的是，我发现自己开始夸大我的德克萨斯特色。比如当我第一次寒假回家时，我姐姐问我圣诞节想要什么，我说：“来双牛仔靴怎么样？”
We are not one self, but many. An instinctual animal and a polite citizen, an unconscious mind and a conscious actor, a shifting cast of characters that are appropriate to our roles as parents, friends, and colleagues. But if discovering your one true self is impossible, is it possible to know your different selves? That's when we come back.
我们不是一个自我，而是许多个。一个本能的动物和一个文明的公民，一个无意识的头脑和一个有意识的行动者，一个根据我们作为父母、朋友和同事的角色而不断变换的演员阵容。但是，如果发现你单一的真实自我是不可能的，那么了解你不同的自我有可能吗？稍后回来，我们将探讨这个问题。
You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Have you experienced a time in your life when you felt like a divided person, where one side of you wanted something, while another wanted something entirely different? How did you resolve this contradiction? Did you resolve this contradiction? If you have a personal story you'd be willing to share with the Hidden Brain audience, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone.
您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。你是否经历过这样的时刻：你感觉自己像个分裂的人，内心的一面想要某种东西，而另一面却想要完全不同的东西？你是如何解决这种矛盾的？你解决了吗？如果你有一个愿意与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享的个人故事，请找一个非常安静的房间，用手机录下一段语音备忘录。
Two or three minutes is plenty. Email it to us at Feedback at HiddenBrain.org. Use the subject line, self-knowledge. Again, that's Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. The poet Walt Whitman famously wrote, Do I contradict myself? Very well. then, I contradict myself. I am large. I contain multitudes. Eric Oliver is the author of
两三分钟就足够了。请通过电子邮件发送给我们，地址是 Feedback@HiddenBrain.org。邮件主题请注明“自我认知”（self-knowledge）。再说一遍，地址是 Feedback@Hiddenbrain.org。诗人沃尔特·惠特曼曾写道：“我是否自相矛盾？好吧，那我就自相矛盾。我博大，我包罗万象。”埃里克·奥利弗是《如何认识你自己：发现真实自我的艺术与科学》一书的作者。
How to Know Yourself, the art and science of discovering who you really are. Eric, after many years of working to reconcile the various parts of yourself, you created a course, the intelligible self, which you've been teaching at the University of Chicago for the past 20 years. What is the aim of this course? Its aim is to help my students expand the vocabulary of their own lived experience. And a lot of us, myself included, especially when we were young, go through living according to stories that we probably didn't write for ourselves. So in order to get my parents' love and approval, I need to be a good boy. If I want to have a happy life, I need to have this high status job. If I want to feel fulfilled, I've got to find this sort of perfect love. And these are
埃里克，在多年致力于调和自身各个部分之后，你创建了一门课程——“可理解的自我”（the intelligible self），并在芝加哥大学教授了20年。这门课程的目的是什么？它的目的是帮助我的学生扩展他们对自己生活体验的词汇量。我们很多人，包括我自己，尤其是在年轻的时候，往往按照那些可能并非我们自己编写的故事生活。为了获得父母的爱和认可，我需要做一个好孩子。如果我想过上幸福的生活，我就需要拥有一份高地位的工作。如果我想感到满足，我就必须找到那种完美的爱情。而这些……
stories that are oftentimes fed to us by our parents or culture or other people. And they're not really the stories that we have figured out for ourselves because we don't necessarily know who we are. And if we want to know who we are, we need to begin to have a richer set of concepts that are available to kind of apprehend, well, what's going on behind this experience of being me? I understand that one of the first precepts in this course is to help students understand not to expect a single unified self. Right. And one of the things I do with the class is I give them a questionnaire and I ask them things
往往是由我们的父母、文化或其他人在我们耳边灌输的故事。它们并不是我们真正为自己想出来的故事，因为我们并不一定知道自己是谁。如果我们想知道自己是谁，我们需要开始拥有一套更丰富的概念，来理解“作为我”的这种体验背后到底发生了什么。我了解到，这门课程的首要准则之一是帮助学生明白，不要期待一个单一的、统一的自我。没错。我在课堂上做的一件事是给他们一份问卷，问他们一些……
like, you know, who are you or what are you? And they typically give me kind of pat answers. You know, I am a sister, I am a daughter, I am a student. And I try to say, well, let's start with that because you're not a sister to me. I'm your professor or you're not a student to your parents. And we begin to see that a lot of the ways that we commonly think of as the singular parts of the self are really just conveniences. Or as I like to describe to them, you know, we are not nouns. We are verbs.
比如，你是谁，或者你是什么？他们通常会给我一些陈词滥调的回答。你知道，我是个姐姐，我是个女儿，我是个学生。我试着说，好吧，让我们从这里开始，因为对我来说你不是姐姐，我是你的教授；或者对你的父母来说，你不是学生。我们开始看到，许多我们通常认为是自我单一组成部分的方式，实际上只是为了方便。或者正如我喜欢向他们描述的那样，我们不是名词，我们是动词。
There's no part of us, you know, down to the molecular level, up to the cellular level, up to the psychological level, that's static. We are beings of constant change and flow. And so a big part of beginning to apprehend what's going on behind this feeling of being me is seeing what is it that's channeling this flow. How is it arising? Where is it out of balance? Where are blockages? How can I make it flow better? I love the idea that we are not nouns but verbs.
我们身上没有任何部分——从分子层面到细胞层面，再到心理层面——是静止的。我们是处于不断变化和流动中的存在。因此，开始理解“作为我”这种感觉背后发生了什么，很大一部分在于观察是什么在引导这种流动。它是如何产生的？哪里失去了平衡？哪里有阻塞？我怎样才能让它流动得更好？我喜欢我们不是名词而是动词这个观点。
And that gets at the idea that it's not just that there are. many of us within each of us, but there are many of us, and these many cells are also constantly changing. So I don't want the same things I wanted 15 years ago. I'm probably not going to want the things I want today 15 years from now. Right. And I think it goes to a misconception I had when I was young, which I thought, oh, if I could just get a handle on this self, like that it was this thing and I could master it, then everything would be fine. And the flip side of that was whenever I was feeling terrible about myself, I felt, well, if I'm this thing, I'm a flawed thing. I'm a bad thing. You know, if I'm feeling discomfort, it must be because I'm somehow
这触及了一个观点，即不仅我们每个人内心都有许多个“我”，而且我们有许多个“我”，这些众多的自我也在不断变化。所以我现在想要的东西和我15年前想要的东西是不一样的。我今天想要的东西，15年后可能也不会再想要了。没错。我认为这指向了我年轻时的一个误解，我当时想，哦，如果我能掌控这个自我，就好像它是一个东西，我可以驾驭它，那么一切都会好起来。而反过来说，每当我对自己感觉糟糕时，我就会觉得，如果我是这个东西，那我就是一个有缺陷的东西，一个糟糕的东西。你知道，如果我感到不适，那一定是因为我……
another broken. And when you let go of thinking of yourself as a thing and you begin to appreciate the far more subtle and difficult idea that you're a process, one of the great things about that is that you'll see these fixed conceptions of yourself begin to melt away. And rather than being a broken thing, maybe you're just a slightly misaligned process. And the good news with that is that processes we can fix. What does it mean to understand that we are a process? Can you give me a tangible feeling of what that means for an individual?
某种程度上坏掉了。当你不再把自己看作一个“东西”，并开始领悟那个更微妙、更困难的观点——即你是一个“过程”时，其中一件伟大的事情就是你会看到那些关于你自己的固定观念开始消融。与其说你是一个坏掉的东西，不如说你只是一个稍微有点失调的过程。而好消息是，过程是可以修复的。理解我们是一个过程意味着什么？你能给我一个关于这对个人意味着什么的具体感受吗？
Where do I take that and how do I run with it? If you engage in a contemplative practice, as you begin to sort of quiet your mind down, and open your consciousness up, what you begin to appreciate about your own physicality is that it always has this effervescence, that we are beings of energy. Now, most of the time, this experience of luminescence is so subtle,
我该如何运用它，又该如何去实践它？如果你进行沉思练习，当你开始让你的头脑平静下来，并打开你的意识时，你开始领悟到关于你自身生理机能的一点是，它总是有一种活力（effervescence），我们是能量的存在。现在，大多数时候，这种发光的体验是如此微妙……
it just gets crowded out in our ordinary consciousness, and we don't really experience it. But the more that we can get in touch with those aspects of ourselves, where we can quiet our minds down, where we can kind of open up our sensory experience, to kind of the more raw, unfiltered information coming through our perceptions, the more glorious our experience of being becomes. And I think this is what is at the heart of a lot of spiritual practices.
它在我们的日常意识中被挤压掉了，我们并没有真正体验到它。但我们越能接触到我们自身的那些方面，越能让我们的头脑平静下来，越能向我们的感官体验敞开，去接收那些通过我们的感知传来的更原始、未经过滤的信息，我们的存在体验就会变得越辉煌。我认为这就是许多精神实践的核心所在。
It's very much at the heart of the contemplative practice. And so a lot of what I'm trying to do with this class, and in some ways with this book, is give people some tools so that they can decompress from a lot of the things that dominate their consciousness and begin to open up some space for this inner feeling of effervescence to make itself more available. One of the philosophers you cite is your own cat. Tell me what your cat has to teach the rest of us, Eric.
这确实是沉思练习的核心。所以，我在这个班级里，在某种程度上通过这本书所做的很多事情，就是给人们提供一些工具，让他们能够从许多主导他们意识的事物中解压，并开始为这种内在的活力感腾出一些空间，使其更容易被感知。你引用的哲学家之一是你的猫。埃里克，告诉我们你的猫能教给我们其他人什么。
Well, one of the things I always notice is that my cat seems to live so much better than I do. Like, she just seems perfectly content in herself. She's happy to stay curled up in a cute little ball. and I have always wondered like why is it that my cat who's a far simpler creature than I am is so much happier than I am and more importantly what is it that I could do to maybe live a little bit more like my cat and one of the things that I'm burdened with that my cat doesn't have is this discursive mind the fact that I'm a creature of language and that language dominates my ordinary consciousness and so a lot of the times I'm there and I'm ruminating and my thoughts are twirling around on one subject or another
嗯，我总是注意到我的猫似乎比我活得好得多。比如，她似乎对自己感到非常满足。她很乐意蜷缩成一个可爱的小球。我一直很纳闷，为什么我的猫——一个比我简单得多的生物——却比我快乐得多？更重要的是，我能做些什么来让自己活得更像我的猫一点？我所背负的、而我的猫所没有的负担，就是这种“话语思维”（discursive mind），即我是一个语言生物，语言主导了我的日常意识。所以很多时候，我坐在那里，在反刍，我的思绪在一个又一个主题上打转……
and I had this mental dialogue going in my head and it's it's kind of the byproduct of being this linguistic being and so a lot of what I try to do to go throughout my day to live in a less encumbered way is to try to be deliberative yet not so caught up in my own thoughts like this morning for example I was I was getting really nervous about this interview and I was like oh I'm going on hidden brain. This is going to be a great thing. But oh, this is a lot of pressure? And I was just thinking, okay, is this thought helping anything? Is my obsessing over about how well I'm going to perform in this conversation really making my life any better? And the answer, like with a lot of my thoughts, was no. And so what can we do in those moments? Well, we can let go of the thought. And to say, okay,
我的脑子里进行着这种心理对话，这是一种作为语言生物的副产品。所以，为了在一天中活得不那么受束缚，我尝试做很多事情，就是努力去深思熟虑，但又不被自己的想法所困。比如今天早上，我对这次采访感到非常紧张，我在想，哦，我要上《隐藏的大脑》了。这会是一件很棒的事情。但哦，这压力好大？我当时就在想，好吧，这个想法有帮助吗？我对自己在这场谈话中表现如何的痴迷，真的让我的生活变得更好了吗？答案，就像我的许多想法一样，是否定的。那么在那些时刻我们能做什么呢？好吧，我们可以放下这个想法。并说，好吧……
that thought's not really working for us. Let's let it go. And maybe just focus on the breath because one of the wonderful things about our existence is that the breath is this one kind of neutral constant. It's this remarkably peaceful place of refuge for us. When our minds are in so much storm, the breath is a place that we can always come back to that has no judgment, that has no criticism that, you know, is just the breath. I like to sort of tell you, my students that, you know, they're really only two certain scenes in life, which are breath and taxes. In many ways, these sound-like practices that are connected to, you know, yoga or meditation.
那个想法对我们并没有什么帮助。让我们放下它吧。也许只是专注于呼吸，因为我们存在的一件美妙的事情是，呼吸是这种中性的常数。它是我们一个非常宁静的避难所。当我们的头脑处于风暴中时，呼吸是我们总是可以回到的地方，它没有评判，没有批评，你知道，它只是呼吸。我喜欢告诉我的学生，生活中其实只有两件确定的事，那就是呼吸和税收。在很多方面，这些听起来像是与瑜伽或冥想相关的练习。
Are these things that you practice, Eric? Yes. So I've been practicing both yoga and meditation for about 30 years. Not in any kind of, like, big, fancy ways. But I try to spend about 15 or 20 minutes meditating every day and try to spend the about 20, 30 minutes doing yoga. And I find these remarkably helpful in terms of stabilizing my mood, helping me keep things in perspective. For someone who isn't in a religious tradition like myself, these are the things that provide me a spiritual discipline, a way of kind of getting in touch with the energies that animate me, that is not simply this world of ideas that I'm so
埃里克，这些是你练习的东西吗？是的。所以我练习瑜伽和冥想已经大约30年了。不是那种很宏大、很花哨的方式。但我每天尝试花15到20分钟冥想，花20到30分钟做瑜伽。我发现这些在稳定我的情绪、帮助我保持客观视角方面非常有帮助。对于像我这样没有宗教传统的人来说，这些是我提供精神纪律的东西，是一种接触那些赋予我活力的能量的方式，而不仅仅是我通常沉浸其中的那个思想世界。
typically caught up in. And I found these incredibly helpful for me in terms of at least helping redress some of the imbalances in myself processes. Do you have students actively try and practice this? Yes, so I will typically teach them a little bit of meditation, partly just to get them a sense of, oh, tasting what might be behind this ordinary experience of being here. So we will sit in class and and I'll say, okay, we're just going to spend the next 10 minutes just focusing on our breath. And we do this and then, and I say at the end of this, okay, how many of you were able to do that? And everyone says, no, I'm thinking about, you know, what's going to be on my phone or what my next exam's going to be or all these things. And I say, okay, well, what's going on behind that?
我发现这些对我非常有帮助，至少能帮助我纠正自我过程中存在的一些失衡。你有让学生积极尝试和练习这些吗？是的，所以我通常会教他们一点冥想，部分只是为了让他们有一种感觉，哦，品味一下这种日常存在体验背后可能是什么。所以我们会在课堂上坐下来，我说，好吧，接下来的10分钟我们只专注于呼吸。我们做了这个，然后我说，好了，有多少人能够做到？每个人都说，不，我在想，你知道，我的手机上会有什么，或者我的下一次考试会是什么，或者所有这些事情。我说，好吧，那这背后发生了什么？
Because remember, all I ask you to do is focus on your breath, that your mind was generating this whole torrent of thoughts and ideas. And that's the beginning where we can begin to apprehend, okay, our thoughts and ideas do not define us, you know, despite what Renee Descartes deduced, we are not just simply beings of thought. We are far more deep and complex than that. And similarly, I sometimes like to take my students and help them do a little yoga too. And it's just simple, sort of stretching. And the reason why I focus on yoga is, I think a big part of living better is this two-step process of, on the one hand, recognizing where our imbalances are and then learning to let go of them.
因为记住，我只要求你专注于呼吸，而你的头脑却产生了一整串的想法和念头。这就是我们开始领悟的起点，即我们的想法和念头并不能定义我们，你知道，尽管勒内·笛卡尔推断过，我们不仅仅是思想的存在。我们比那要深刻和复杂得多。同样，我有时也喜欢带我的学生做一点瑜伽。这只是简单的拉伸。我专注于瑜伽的原因是，我认为活得更好的很大一部分是这个两步过程：一方面，认识到我们的失衡在哪里，然后学习放下它们。
And one of the things that I try to teach them is that letting go is not a passive activity. We often think about letting go is, oh, I'm just going to let go of it and just kind of kick back. And that's not really how we work. If we really want to let go, that's a vigorous, engaged activity for us. It's about actively pushing back against these habitual patterns, these kind of system one and system two thinking routines that typically dominate our consciousness. And in cultivating a more deliberate way to live, we have to kind of push back against those mental habits. And that takes a lot of work. It's a very vigorous engaging activity.
我试图教给他们的一件事是，放下不是一种被动活动。我们经常认为放下就是，哦，我只是要放下它，然后往后一靠。但我们并不是那样运作的。如果我们真的想放下，那对我们来说是一种积极的、投入的活动。它是关于积极地反抗这些习惯性模式，这些通常主导我们意识的“系统一”和“系统二”思维惯例。在培养一种更深思熟虑的生活方式时，我们必须反抗那些心理习惯。这需要做很多工作。这是一项非常积极、投入的活动。
And interestingly, yoga is kind of an interesting metaphor for this. Because when we're doing yoga, we're not just simply just kicking back and stretching. We're engaging some muscles to loosen up others. And so I think the yoga practice, at least as far as like the physical asanas that we do in the West, which we call yoga, are really good lessons in that engagement with letting go. You talked to me earlier about the idea that, you know, all of life is interconnected, that there is a single source, a common ancestor that connects everything on Earth. You say that there are times in your life when you feel these different cells inside you are all connected
有趣的是，瑜伽是这方面的一个有趣的隐喻。因为当我们做瑜伽时，我们不仅仅是往后一靠进行拉伸。我们正在调动一些肌肉来放松另一些肌肉。所以我认为瑜伽练习，至少就我们在西方所做的身体体式（asanas）而言，确实是那种“放下”的很好的一课。你之前跟我谈到过这样一个观点，即生命的一切都是相互关联的，有一个单一的源头，一个连接地球上一切事物的共同祖先。你说你生命中有一些时刻，你感觉到内心这些不同的自我都是连接在一起的……
and not just with each other, but with other creatures as well. Talk about these moments, Eric. They almost sound mystical. They are. I have one experience in particular that stands out. So when I was younger, I used to go backpacking in the wilderness by myself. And for anyone who's done this, backpacking by yourself in the wilderness is both exhilarating and horrifying. It's really scary, especially at night when you're there and you feel very, very vulnerable.
不仅彼此连接，而且与其他生物也连接在一起。埃里克，谈谈这些时刻吧。它们听起来几乎是神秘的。确实如此。我有一个特别的经历让我印象深刻。我年轻的时候，经常独自去荒野背包旅行。对于任何做过这件事的人来说，独自在荒野中背包旅行既令人振奋又令人恐惧。这真的很可怕，尤其是在晚上，当你身处其中，感到非常、非常脆弱的时候。
And then there are all the sounds of the wilderness kind of coming up and it's in the dark. and I would often find myself having a hard time falling asleep because I was just convinced that there was some bear or cougar or axe-wielding maniac who was about to come and get me. And one night I said, okay, I'm going to flip the script on this. And I started thinking, instead of hearing every rustle in the bushes as an imminent threat, I would think of them as friendly helloes
然后荒野中所有的声音都在黑暗中响起，我经常发现自己很难入睡，因为我确信有什么熊、美洲狮或挥舞斧头的疯子正要来抓我。有一天晚上我说，好吧，我要改变这种剧本。我开始想，与其把灌木丛中的每一次沙沙声都当作迫在眉睫的威胁，我不如把它们当作友好的问候……
because all of these other creatures are my cousins in the life force. We are all part of the same fire of life that has been going on this planet for at least 3.7 billion years. We're all different expressions of this. To use another metaphor, it's like we're all, there's one big tree of life and we're all just very, very different leaves. And once I was able to sort of tap into that, this really deep feeling of kind of continuity and connection really just enveloped me. That kind of lonely vulnerability that I oftentimes feel and carry around really went away. Now, that was also a bit of an illusion because, yeah, sure, a lot of those animals probably would have happily made a meal out of me given the opportunity. And it's both kind of a wonderful thing and a mixed blessing for us because on the one hand, it means we're never truly alone.
因为所有这些其他生物都是我在生命力中的表亲。我们都是同一个生命之火的一部分，这把火在地球上已经燃烧了至少37亿年。我们都是这种生命的不同表达。用另一个隐喻来说，就像我们都是一棵巨大的生命之树，而我们都只是非常、非常不同的叶子。一旦我能够触及这一点，这种关于连续性和连接的深刻感觉就真的包围了我。那种我经常感到并随身携带的孤独脆弱感真的消失了。现在，那也有一点幻觉的成分，因为，是的，当然，如果给它们机会，那些动物中的许多可能很乐意把我当成一顿美餐。这既是一件美妙的事情，也是一种喜忧参半的祝福，因为一方面，这意味着我们永远不会真正孤独。
Like I said earlier, we are an amalgamation of different beings coming together that are underneath this experience of an eye, a singular eye. and part of I think knowing ourselves and opening up our minds to ourselves is getting more in touch with a more collective sense of being that I am just not an eye I am both this multicellular creature but I'm also connected with everyone else around me my self processes do not exist in isolation they are the byproduct of my social interactions so we are deeply interconnected on the other hand it also means that each of us doesn't really matter all that much and that's a bit of a gut punch, at least for me, because I like to believe that I'm special and that I'm distinctive, but really I'm not. And so part of appreciating that is also letting go of this kind of egoistic conceit that somehow another, you know,
就像我之前说的，我们是不同生物的集合体，在“我”——一个单一的“我”——的体验之下汇聚在一起。我认为认识自己并向自己敞开心扉的一部分，就是更多地接触一种更集体的存在感，即我不仅仅是一个“我”，我既是这个多细胞生物，也与周围的每个人相连。我的自我过程并非孤立存在，它们是我社会互动的副产品。所以我们是深度互联的。另一方面，这也意味着我们每个人其实并没有那么重要。这对我来说有点像当头一棒，因为我喜欢相信我是特别的，我是独特的，但实际上我并不是。所以领悟这一点的一部分，也是放下那种自负的虚荣心，即某种程度上……
I am distinct in the universe. And I think the more that we can actually let go of that, the more peaceful our experience of being becomes. When you look within, who do you see? Is there a coherent sense? a singular I, a noun, as Eric Oliver puts it? Or do you see yourself as a verb in a state of flux and evolution? This question animates many aspects of human behavior.
我在宇宙中是独特的。我认为我们越能真正放下这一点，我们的存在体验就越平静。当你向内看时，你看到了谁？有一种连贯的感觉吗？一个单一的“我”，一个名词，正如埃里克·奥利弗所说的那样？还是你把自己看作一个处于变动和进化状态中的动词？这个问题激发了人类行为的许多方面。
One domain where it is particularly salient is intelligence. Do you think of your cognitive abilities as fixed or as something that can vary based on your environment and experiences? Recently, we heard from a listener named Darby. She says she excelled at school. I did very well on IQ tests as a kid and was told I was very smart by the test results and by my parents and by my grades. I'm good at language and math and seeing patterns. It seems like that's what is tested.
一个特别突出的领域是智力。你认为你的认知能力是固定的，还是会根据你的环境和经历而变化的？最近，我们收到了一位名叫达比的听众的来信。她说她在学校表现优异。“我小时候在智商测试中表现非常好，测试结果、我的父母和我的成绩都告诉我我很聪明。我擅长语言、数学和观察模式。看起来这就是测试的内容。”
But outside of school, Darby didn't feel particularly smart. Just really like not very aware of my surroundings or the names of things don't stick. I could go on a trip and not really tell you where I was, stuff like that. So it produced a lot of confusion for me. I didn't understand why if I was so smart, why did I not actually seem that smart in the world in a lot of ways? It was almost like Darby had multiple selves, the one who could ace a tricky math test
“但在学校之外，达比并不觉得自己特别聪明。只是真的不太注意周围的环境，或者事物的名字记不住。我可以去旅行，却说不出我在哪里，诸如此类的事情。所以这给我带来了很多困惑。我不明白，如果我那么聪明，为什么我在现实世界中看起来并不那么聪明？这几乎就像达比有多个自我，那个能在棘手的数学测试中取得好成绩的自我……”
and the one who struggled to navigate an unfamiliar neighborhood. Many people feel this way when it comes to intelligence. We feel smart in some domains, but not in others. We shine on a science test, but cannot figure out how to form a proper thesis for an English paper. We can invent a daring new recipe, but forget to bring our shopping list to the grocery store. Our society tends to hold up highly intelligent people as heroes. Leonardo da Vinci, Marie Curie, Albert Einstein. And for good reason, their insights have led to countless.
和那个在不熟悉的社区中挣扎的自我。许多人在谈到智力时都有这种感觉。我们在某些领域感到聪明，但在其他领域则不然。我们在科学测试中表现出色，却无法弄清楚如何为英语论文写出合适的论点。我们可以发明一种大胆的新食谱，却忘记带购物清单去杂货店。我们的社会倾向于把高智商的人奉为英雄。列奥纳多·达·芬奇、玛丽·居里、阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦。这是有充分理由的，他们的见解带来了无数的……
breakthroughs and innovations. But when we use words like intelligent or smart or gifted, what exactly do we mean? And are we prioritizing a certain kind of intelligence and ignoring the people who don't fit that definition? Are we thinking of intelligence as a noun and not as a verb? When we come back, what it really means to be smart? You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. From an early age, children develop a sense of their aptitude as students. In many schools, tests play an important role in determining which students are tracked into gifted programs and which are not. But what if the tests we use to make these judgments prioritize a certain kind of intelligence?
突破和创新。但是，当我们使用“聪明”（intelligent）、“机灵”（smart）或“天才”（gifted）这些词时，我们到底是什么意思？我们是否在优先考虑某种特定的智力，而忽视了那些不符合该定义的人？我们是否把智力看作一个名词而不是一个动词？回来后，我们将探讨“聪明”的真正含义。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。从很小的时候起，孩子们就形成了对自己作为学生能力的认知。在许多学校，测试在决定哪些学生被分入天才班、哪些不被分入方面起着重要作用。但如果我们用来做出这些判断的测试优先考虑的是某种特定的智力呢？
That's a question that has long animated Scott Barry Kaufman, a psychologist at Columbia University who studies the science of human potential. Scott was a guest on a Hidden Brain episode titled why you're smarter than you think. Today, he returns to the show to respond to listener questions and comments about his work. Scott Barry Kaufman, welcome back to Hidden Brain.
这是一个长期以来一直激发哥伦比亚大学心理学家斯科特·巴里·考夫曼研究的问题，他研究人类潜能的科学。斯科特曾是《隐藏的大脑》一期名为“为什么你比你想象的更聪明”的嘉宾。今天，他回到节目中，回应听众关于他工作的提问和评论。斯科特·巴里·考夫曼，欢迎回到《隐藏的大脑》。
Thank you. That's so great to be here. Scott, in our last conversation, we talked about IQ tests and how they came to be used in the United States. Tell me a little bit of that history again. How did the IQ test come about? Well, one of the first IQ tests was not actually called an IQ test,
谢谢。很高兴来到这里。斯科特，在我们上次的谈话中，我们谈到了智商测试以及它们是如何在美国开始使用的。再给我们讲讲那段历史吧。智商测试是怎么来的？嗯，最早的智商测试其实并不叫智商测试……
it was actually called an intelligence test. It was Alfred Bernay, a Frenchman, was tasked by the Department of Education there to come up with a test that would differentiate those who needed help in school versus those that didn't need help in school. And it was never thought of by Benet as an intelligence test. But that was a couple Americans, including Lewis Terman at Stanford, who discovered those tests and saw opportunities to measure genius with them. And basically an individually administered test, like a one-on-one very intimate test that was created by Alfred Bernay was converted into a multiple-choice mass-produced test that was used for all sorts of purposes that didn't have its original intent. And sadly, you know, Alfred Bernay died quite angry at Americans and frustrated because the purpose of the test was never used in France. And he saw how it was being used in America. What do IQ tests purport to measure, Scott, and what aspects of intelligence might they be overlooking?
它实际上被称为“智力测试”。阿尔弗雷德·比奈，一位法国人，受当地教育部委托，设计一种测试来区分那些在学校需要帮助的学生和那些不需要帮助的学生。比奈从未将其视为一种智力测试。但有几个美国人，包括斯坦福大学的路易斯·特曼，发现了这些测试，并看到了用它们来衡量天才的机会。基本上，由阿尔弗雷德·比奈创建的个人管理测试——一种一对一的、非常亲密的测试——被转化为一种多项选择、大规模生产的测试，被用于各种并非其初衷的目的。可悲的是，你知道，阿尔弗雷德·比奈死时对美国人非常愤怒和沮丧，因为这种测试的目的在法国从未被这样使用过。他看到了它在美国是如何被使用的。斯科特，智商测试声称衡量什么，而它们可能忽略了智力的哪些方面？
IQ tests measure a bunch of different cognitive abilities, vocabulary, spatial rotation, working memory. So it's measuring a set of cognitive skills that aren't irrelevant to our lives, aren't important. But I think the big question is, you know, do we want to put the label intelligence on the sets of skills and and to what degree if we aren't sky high in those things is it really limiting us in our potential and those are the kind of questions that that really animate me. Scott, we heard from many listeners who struggled with IQ tests when they were students. Here's Jamie. School was always painful or maybe scary is a better word as I was always scared and almost crying when I had English and social studies that day. Anytime there was a test, I was always the last one out of the room and would
智商测试衡量一系列不同的认知能力：词汇、空间旋转、工作记忆。所以它衡量的是一套对我们的生活并非无关紧要、并非不重要的认知技能。但我认为最大的问题是，你知道，我们是否想把“智力”这个标签贴在这些技能集上？如果我们在这方面不是顶尖的，它是否真的限制了我们的潜能？这些就是真正激发我的那种问题。斯科特，我们收到了许多听众的来信，他们学生时代在智商测试中挣扎。这是杰米。“学校总是很痛苦，或者用‘可怕’这个词可能更准确，因为我总是很害怕，那天上英语和社科课时几乎要哭出来。每次有考试，我总是最后一个离开教室，而且会……”
see the teacher looking at me with a, what's wrong with you look in her eyes? Then there was the less frequent big tests that I understood were IQ tests. Again, I was always the last one out of the room, and when the two hours were up, I would only have about two-thirds of the test complete, and it would be taken away from me. I felt broken and different than all my peers. So, Scott, I think I can hear the pain that Jamie felt when he did not perform well on these tests. Talk a little bit about your own experience with these tests, and why it is for many people, these tests have come to be something of a referendum on our feelings of self-worth. Well, I definitely resonate with Jamie.
看到老师用一种“你有什么毛病”的眼神看着我。然后是频率较低的大型考试，我知道那是智商测试。同样，我总是最后一个离开教室，当两个小时结束时，我只能完成三分之二的测试，然后它就被收走了。我感到自己破碎了，与所有的同龄人不同。所以，斯科特，我想我能听到杰米在这些测试中表现不佳时的痛苦。谈谈你自己对这些测试的经历，以及为什么对许多人来说，这些测试已经成为一种关于我们自我价值感的公投。嗯，我绝对能与杰米产生共鸣。
I had two major IQ testing sessions. One, I could barely hear the test instructor because I had this auditory processing disability at that time, and I remember leaving that feeling like, oh, my gosh, they're going to think I'm really stupid. The second one was to decide what special school I should be sent to in fifth grade. And so just having that in my mind already, that they're giving me a test to figure out which school for the learning disabled they should send me to all. It didn't really set it off on a good foot there. So yeah, I mean, it's just, there's so much intense.
我有过两次重大的智商测试经历。第一次，我几乎听不清测试指导员的声音，因为我当时有听觉处理障碍，我记得离开时感觉，哦，天哪，他们会认为我真的很笨。第二次是为了决定我在五年级应该被送去哪所特殊学校。所以，仅仅是脑子里有这个想法，他们给我做测试是为了弄清楚应该把我送到哪所学习障碍学校，这并没有让我有一个好的开始。所以，是的，我的意思是，这真的有太多的紧张感……
You feel this pressure on you. You feel like some deep part of you is being evaluated. It's, you know, they don't think that's going to make too many people feel good. Hmm. So that's one side of the testing coin Scott. We also heard a different point of view from a listener named Carla. She grew up in rural Iowa in the 1970s. We were all required to take an IQ test and an inventory of basic skills and interests
你感到压力压在身上。你觉得你内心深处的一部分正在被评估。你知道，他们不认为这会让太多人感觉良好。嗯。所以这是测试硬币的一面，斯科特。我们也从一位名叫卡拉的听众那里听到了不同的观点。她在20世纪70年代的爱荷华州农村长大。“我们都被要求参加智商测试和基本技能与兴趣清单的评估……”
so that we could guide our future education. I never thought I was all that smart, but I must have done well on the test because the guidance counselor at the school met with my mother and told her, Carla can do anything she chooses to do. She's very smart and she can do anything. So over the years, my mother has reminded me of that when I thought maybe I couldn't make it through something or I didn't have what I needed. And it has definitely and absolutely been kind of a foundation.
以便我们可以指导未来的教育。我从没想过自己那么聪明，但我一定在测试中表现得很好，因为学校的指导顾问和我母亲见了面，告诉她：“卡拉可以选择做任何她想做的事。她非常聪明，她可以做任何事。”所以多年来，当我以为自己可能无法完成某件事或者没有我所需要的东西时，我母亲都会提醒我这一点。它绝对、绝对成为了一种基础。
So whether it was true or not, it gave me the courage and the confidence. to just try whatever I needed to do. I'm wondering if this is one of the benefits of standardized testing, Scott. When we perform well on these tests, can they give us confidence to attempt difficult things? Yes, I think that there's really important nuance here, which is that these tests can be very useful tools, and they shouldn't be used to limit possibility or limit potential. Both things can be true at the same time.
所以无论它是真是假，它都给了我尝试任何我需要做的事情的勇气和信心。我在想，这是否是标准化测试的好处之一，斯科特？当我们这些测试中表现良好时，它们能给我们尝试困难事物的信心吗？是的，我认为这里确实有非常重要的细微差别，那就是这些测试可以是非常有用的工具，它们不应该被用来限制可能性或限制潜能。两件事可以同时成立。
It's not a contradiction. to say that the tests are reliable and valid in the sense they're measuring a certain slice of human cognition, which some people score very high in those things. And it can actually tap into some people's hidden potential for sure. For sure. I mean, I imagine that a lot, if not most physics professors, you know, did well in an IQ test when they're younger or, you know, certain fields. it can kind of test maybe your promise for certain things. But I think that that's the nuance we need is to simultaneously acknowledge that there are people
说测试在某种意义上是可靠和有效的，即它们衡量的是人类认知的一个特定切片，有些人在这方面得分很高，这并不矛盾。它确实可以挖掘出一些人隐藏的潜能。当然。我的意思是，我想很多，如果不是大多数物理学教授，你知道，在年轻时在智商测试中表现良好，或者，你知道，某些领域。它可以测试你对某些事情的承诺。但我认为这就是我们需要细微差别的地方，即同时承认有这样的人……
who are intellectually gifted in a certain way that deserve just as much appreciation and acceleration as any other student. I'm an advocate of gifted education. My whole thing is expanding the pie of and doing universal screening and a lot of other nuanced stuff that we could talk about. but I don't want to get rid of gifted education. In some ways, the story that Carla tells reminds me of the story that you told us about how you took an IQ test at one point that found that you were profoundly gifted and that result was so important to your sense of self that you taped it to the wall of your bedroom.
他们在某种程度上具有智力天赋，应该像任何其他学生一样得到同样的欣赏和加速培养。我是天才教育的倡导者。我的全部主张是扩大蛋糕，进行普遍筛查以及我们可以谈论的许多其他细微差别。但我不想取消天才教育。在某种程度上，卡拉讲述的故事让我想起了你告诉我们的故事，关于你曾经参加过一次智商测试，发现你是极具天赋的，而那个结果对你的自我意识非常重要，以至于你把它贴在了卧室的墙上。
That's right. Oh my God. I forgot I told you that. Yeah, I remember vividly that I put that on my wall. I mean, I don't know if it was healthy, you know, my obsession was. with my intelligence. I'm not saying that was a great thing, you know, like, why did I need that for my ego? I mean, that was around the time where I thought that everyone thought I was stupid. So it was exciting for me to, like, I remember telling my parents, like, look, you know, I took this test online that says I'm a genius. It felt great.
没错。天哪。我忘了我告诉过你那个。是的，我清楚地记得我把它贴在墙上。我的意思是，我不知道我的痴迷是否健康。关于我的智力。我不是说那是一件好事，你知道，比如，为什么我的自我需要那个？我的意思是，那大约是我认为每个人都觉得我很笨的时候。所以对我来说很兴奋，比如，我记得告诉我的父母，看，你知道，我在网上参加了这个测试，说我是天才。感觉很棒。
But I don't know how healthy that is, to be honest. Maybe that was a little narcissistic of me. We spoke some time ago on Hidden Brain with the psychologist Peter Gray, and he told us, about how his son hated school until he started going to a school where students guided their own learning based on their interests. There were not any assessments in the traditional sense. Now, for some students, it seems that doing away with testing altogether can give them the space to actually learn, but there are also many circumstances in which an assessment can be very useful to give teachers a sense of what students understand about a topic.
但我不知道那有多健康，说实话。也许那对我来说有点自恋。我们很久以前在《隐藏的大脑》中与心理学家彼得·格雷交谈过，他告诉我们他的儿子是如何讨厌学校的，直到他开始去一所学生根据自己的兴趣引导自己学习的学校。那里没有任何传统意义上的评估。现在，对于一些学生来说，取消测试似乎可以给他们空间去真正学习，但也有许多情况下，评估对于让老师了解学生对某个主题的理解程度非常有用。
I'm wondering what you think about the extent and purpose of testing in our educational system, Scott, and how you would change things if you could, you know, you could be the emperor of our educational system for a day. Yeah, you know, if more humbly, if I was Secretary of Education, then I would, what I would do. And I used to dream of being Secretary of Education when I was younger. But what I would definitely emphasize is the fact that we put way, you know, policies matter. And we put so much of our funding and money into assessment. that there's very little leftover for programming. And I would absolutely redistribute that
我在想你如何看待我们教育系统中测试的范围和目的，斯科特，如果你能改变事情，你会怎么做，你知道，你可以当一天的教育系统皇帝。是的，你知道，如果更谦虚一点，如果我是教育部长，那么我会，我会怎么做。我年轻时曾梦想成为教育部长。但我绝对会强调这样一个事实，即我们投入了太多的……政策很重要。我们把太多的资金和金钱投入到评估中，以至于剩下的编程（programming）资金很少。我绝对会重新分配它……
and acknowledge that programming will enhance all students. This idea that only certain students who meet a certain arbitrary threshold or cutoff on a standardized test are worthy or deserving of enriched resources is one that, quite frankly, Shankar, makes my head explode. A listener named Jonathan called in with a philosophic. question, Scott, about how we measure ability and also what that says about our priorities as a society. Your piece brought to mind the question, what dignity does a human being deserve from his or her peers and on what grounds? Aren't the contents an import of the IQ test
并承认编程将增强所有学生的能力。这种认为只有达到标准化测试中某个任意阈值或截止点的特定学生才值得或配得上丰富资源的观点，坦率地说，尚卡尔，让我的头都要炸了。一位名叫乔纳森的听众打来电话，提出了一个哲学问题，斯科特，关于我们如何衡量能力，以及这对于我们作为一个社会的优先事项意味着什么。“你的文章让我想到了这个问题：一个人从同龄人那里应该得到什么尊严，基于什么理由？智商测试的内容难道不是……”
indicative of how our society chooses to value one another? What we value comes through in the chart that relates IQ score to prevailing notions of success. What would a test look like if our society dignified qualities of self-sacrifice and peaceful problem-solving over academic and professional achievement? What do you make of Jonathan's comments, Scott? I love that. I love all these questions are so thoughtful. I really like Jonathan's question a lot.
表明我们社会选择如何评价彼此的指标吗？我们所珍视的东西体现在智商分数与普遍成功观念相关的图表中。如果我们的社会将自我牺牲和和平解决问题的品质置于学术和职业成就之上，测试会是什么样子？斯科特，你如何看待乔纳森的评论？我喜欢这个。我喜欢所有这些问题，它们都非常深思熟虑。我真的很喜欢乔纳森的问题。
This test measures general intelligence, and we overvalue general intelligence. We don't need to expand the definition of general intelligence to encompass every talent and skill and every single characteristic, human characteristic. Instead, what we need to acknowledge is that we overvalue general intelligence and don't really appreciate talents,
这个测试衡量的是一般智力，而我们过度评价了一般智力。我们不需要扩大一般智力的定义来涵盖每一种才能、技能和每一种特征、人类特征。相反，我们需要承认的是，我们过度评价了一般智力，并没有真正欣赏才能……
the character, from, like, creativity to love, to spirituality. I mean, those are the building blocks of a good life, not your IQ-type cognition. I mean, when you think about the people whom you might want to have as friends or as life partners, you know, sure, people want to have intelligent friends and intelligent life partners, but I think many of us would say qualities such as kindness or compassion or reliability or loyalty, these things in the end, they matter so much more. I think what we're really getting here in this conversation, what's emerging, is this idea that self-actualization and the journey of self-actualization is such an intensely personal process that to have standardized tests that kind of have this assumption that we're testing your potential in life based on these general standardized things where you're being compared to other people. That's the problem, really, if you want it in a nutshell.
品格，从创造力到爱，再到灵性。我的意思是，那些是美好生活的基石，而不是你的智商型认知。我的意思是，当你想到你可能想作为朋友或生活伴侣的人时，你知道，当然，人们想拥有聪明的伙伴和聪明的生活伴侣，但我认为我们许多人会说，善良、同情心、可靠或忠诚等品质，这些东西最终要重要得多。我认为我们在这场谈话中真正触及的，正在浮现的，是这样一个观点：自我实现和自我实现的旅程是一个极其个人的过程，以至于拥有那种假设我们基于这些一般标准化事物来测试你的生活潜能、并将你与他人进行比较的标准化测试。如果你想简而言之，这就是问题所在。
When we come back, a teacher's perspective, plus the many factors that can shape how we perform as students. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. We all want to believe that we're capable, that we're clever, that we're intelligent. But how do we know that we are smart? Do standard methods to measure intelligence reflect who we are or what we're capable of doing? At Columbia University, Scott Barry Kaufman studies the science of human intelligence. Today, he's responding to listener comments and questions about his work.
回来后，教师的视角，以及可能影响我们作为学生表现的许多因素。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们都想相信自己是有能力的，是聪明的，是智慧的。但我们怎么知道我们是聪明的呢？衡量智力的标准方法反映了我们是谁，或者我们有能力做什么吗？在哥伦比亚大学，斯科特·巴里·考夫曼研究人类智力的科学。今天，他正在回应听众关于他工作的评论和提问。
Scott, we've seen how students believe that standardized tests reveal something innate about them. Listener Terin was an educator for 31 years. She worries about how these tests affect the way teachers see young people. I am concerned that testing creates this idea about who the student is for teachers and counselors and psychologists and affects us in how we see that student and what we expect from them. And so I think we have to be very careful about how we use these tests, what we do with them, and to educate people about the importance of seeing the whole child and our expectations of them.
斯科特，我们已经看到学生们相信标准化测试揭示了关于他们天生的某些东西。听众特琳做了31年的教育工作者。她担心这些测试如何影响老师看待年轻人的方式。“我担心测试会为老师、辅导员和心理学家创造出关于学生是谁的这种想法，并影响我们看待该学生的方式以及我们对他们的期望。所以我认为我们必须非常小心我们如何使用这些测试，我们用它们做什么，并教育人们关于看待‘完整儿童’（whole child）以及我们对他们的期望的重要性。”
What do you think, Scott, do these tests brand-we- one student is smart in her teacher's eyes and brand another one is slow? Well, I want to pick up on something that Turin said there at the end is that seeing the whole child, that's it. That's the key there is that we all contain multitudes. We're all brimming with our areas of strengths and our areas of weaknesses. And most of these tests are not designed to capture the whole person. They're designed to capture a slice that will try to predict your further test scores.
斯科特，你认为这些测试是否给一个学生贴上了“聪明”的标签，而在老师眼中给另一个学生贴上了“迟钝”的标签？嗯，我想接着特琳最后说的那一点，即“看待完整儿童”，就是这样。关键在于我们每个人都包罗万象。我们都充满了我们的优势领域和劣势领域。而这些测试中的大多数并不是为了捕捉完整的人而设计的。它们旨在捕捉一个试图预测你未来测试成绩的切片。
It's like test scores are trying to predict further test scores, which are then going to predict, will that get you into Wall School? And then will that get you into the nursing home you want eventually? You know what I mean? It never ends. One thing that strikes me in this conversation, Scott, is that there's only so much one can do inside school to foster a student's success. There's so much that happens outside the classroom
这就像考试成绩试图预测未来的考试成绩，而这些成绩又将预测你是否能进入华尔街学校？然后最终是否能让你进入你心仪的养老院？你明白我的意思吗？这没完没了。在这个对话中，有一件事让我印象深刻，斯科特，那就是在学校里能做的事情非常有限，无法完全促进学生的成功。课堂之外发生的事情太多了
that also impacts how a student will fare when she takes a test. Some listeners called in with questions about how childhood trauma can affect intelligence. Others, like listener Chi, want to talk about traits like resilience and adaptability. Growing up, I moved between China, Poland, and the U.S.
这也影响了学生参加考试时的表现。一些听众打来电话，询问童年创伤如何影响智力。其他人，比如听众Chi，想谈谈韧性和适应力等特质。在成长过程中，我在中国、波兰和美国之间搬迁。
Often changing schools every six months to a year That constant moving made me feel like I was always behind or somehow dumb, even though I was keeping up, adapting, and surviving in completely new environments. I think a lot of that feeling came from how intelligence was measured via grades, tests, and how teachers and adults generally correlated them with a child's potential unworth. Like Scott, as a child, I could sense that something wasn't right. The fact was, I had to navigate between. languages, cultures, and systems, and I had to figure out how to keep pace without really being able to compare myself to anyone else due to lack of friends and neglect. Deep down, I suspected that I was doing well, just in ways that wasn't recognized or captured
经常每六个月到一年就换一次学校。那种不断的搬迁让我觉得我总是落后，或者在某种程度上很笨，尽管我一直在跟上进度、适应并在这个全新的环境中生存下来。我认为这种感觉很大程度上源于智力是如何通过成绩、考试来衡量的，以及老师和成年人通常如何将这些与孩子的潜力和价值联系起来。像斯科特一样，小时候我就能感觉到有些不对劲。事实是，我必须在语言、文化和系统之间穿梭，我必须弄清楚如何保持节奏，却因为缺乏朋友和被忽视而无法真正与任何人比较。在内心深处，我怀疑自己做得很好，只是方式没有被传统学校教育所认可或捕捉到。
by traditional schooling. As I've grown, I see that this pattern shaped how I approach life and work. I adapted quickly, recognized patterns across fields, and can solve problems in ways that formal tests never measured. Listening to your episode reminded me that intelligence isn't just about what shows up on paper or even what professionals claim. So it's notable that Chi showed a lot of resilience during her many moves around the world. She navigated vastly different school systems and cultures.
随着我的成长，我发现这种模式塑造了我对待生活和工作的方式。我适应得很快，能识别各领域的模式，并能以正式考试从未衡量过的方式解决问题。听了你们的节目，我意识到智力不仅仅是纸面上显示的东西，甚至不仅仅是专业人士所声称的那样。所以值得注意的是，Chi在世界各地的多次搬迁中表现出了极大的韧性。她驾驭了截然不同的学校系统和文化。
What role do you think resilience and adaptability should play when we talk about intelligence, Scott? Yeah, I'm really touched by Chi's comments. I got chills. listening to it and a little bit emotional. What kind of stinks a little bit is that, yes, she showed so much resiliency, but none of that counts. There are so many things that just don't count. They're not like being valued.
斯科特，你认为当我们谈论智力时，韧性和适应力应该扮演什么角色？是的，我真的被Chi的评论感动了。听的时候我起了一身鸡皮疙瘩，还有点情绪化。有点糟糕的是，是的，她表现出了如此多的韧性，但这些都不算数。有太多事情根本不算数。它们没有被重视。
They're not being because they're not being measured, you know. And there's so much that she is showing the school system she's actually able to withstand. And the ways that she's able to draw connections between different cultures. And there's so much, she's bringing with so much potential, but because of her situation, her working memory is being overloaded. And so she's not able to, like, demonstrate in testing situations, you know, that make huge demands on memory, you know, what she's really capable of. So my heart breaks in a really big way when I hear those kinds of stories.
它们没有被重视，因为它们没有被衡量，你知道的。她向学校系统展示了她实际上能够承受的东西，以及她能够建立不同文化之间联系的方式，这些都太多了。她带来了如此多的潜力，但由于她的处境，她的工作记忆超负荷了。所以她无法在那些对记忆力要求极高的考试情境中，展示出她真正的能力。所以当我听到这些故事时，我的心真的很痛。
And I hear these kinds of stories all the time. So this is, there's something really pervasive about this that we're maybe not talking about as openly in society as we should be. As we discussed in our last episode, Scott, as an intelligence researcher, you spent a lot of time studying the relationship between intelligence as measured by IQ tests and life outcomes. Can you talk a moment about that? What does the data tell us about the relationship between those two things?
我一直都在听到这类故事。所以，这其中有一些非常普遍的东西，也许我们在社会中并没有像应该的那样公开讨论。正如我们在上一集讨论的那样，斯科特，作为一名智力研究员，你花了很多时间研究智商测试所衡量的智力与生活结果之间的关系。你能谈谈这一点吗？数据告诉我们这两者之间有什么关系？
Okay, so we talked earlier about how context matters. And depending on what we're trying to predict statistically, IQ has a stronger, prediction and a less strong prediction. So when it comes to the arts, for instance, and that's a wide swath of things from creative writing to visual arts to music performance, we've published papers showing a zero correlation with IQ and creative achievement in the arts. Within the sciences, some fields show much stronger correlation than others, fields that are very math-heavy, physics-heavy, really draw on what we're really talking about here is abstract reasoning ability, your ability to really generalize and think of this very abstract, like philosophy, you know, is even correlated
好的，我们之前谈过背景的重要性。根据我们试图在统计学上预测的内容，智商的预测力有强有弱。例如，当涉及到艺术时，这涵盖了从创意写作到视觉艺术再到音乐表演的广泛领域，我们发表的论文显示，智商与艺术领域的创造性成就之间没有相关性。在科学领域，有些领域表现出比其他领域更强的相关性，那些数学密集型、物理密集型的领域，确实利用了我们在这里真正讨论的抽象推理能力，即你概括和思考这种非常抽象事物的能力，比如哲学，甚至与智商相关，
with IQ, especially like logic form of philosophy, where you have to hold lots of things in your working memory, and, you know, IQ matters for that kind of stuff. And so it really depends on what you're trying to predict, but even within those fields, you always, you have so many exceptions. I'm wondering if you think, Scott, that these tests are better used as a compass, in that they give us directional guidance, but not really precision guidance. Wow, that's really clever. Yeah, I think that there are tools that can provide information about a person's patterns of strengths and weaknesses cognitively,
尤其是逻辑形式的哲学，你必须在工作记忆中保持很多东西，你知道，智商对这类事情很重要。所以这确实取决于你试图预测什么，但即使在这些领域内，你也总是有很多例外。斯科特，我想知道你是否认为这些测试最好被用作指南针，因为它们给我们提供了方向性的指导，而不是精确的指导。哇，这真的很聪明。是的，我认为有些工具可以提供关于一个人认知上的优势和劣势模式的信息，
and we have to recognize that there are so many other human attributes that are brought to the table in the process of self-actualization, especially as we become adults and we leave. grade school. So we need to hold all these things in mind at once, but I really like the way you put that. Scott, in the United States and also in other countries around the world, students from wealthy families often do better on standardized tests. In the U.S., for example, wealthy families, kids from wealthy families often do better on the SAT, for example. I'm wondering how you explain this and what this says about how we should use IQ tests in educational systems.
我们必须认识到，在自我实现的过程中，还有许多其他人类属性被带入其中，尤其是当我们成年并离开小学时。所以我们需要同时记住所有这些事情，但我真的很喜欢你的这种说法。斯科特，在美国以及世界其他国家，来自富裕家庭的学生在标准化考试中往往表现更好。例如，在美国，富裕家庭的孩子在SAT考试中往往表现更好。我想知道你是如何解释这一点的，以及这对于我们应该如何在教育系统中使用智商测试意味着什么。
election. There's something called the Matthew effect in psychology where the rich get richer and the poor get poorer. And you do find that very small advantages when you young can really compound, when you give people resources. And then over time, you see these huge differences and you say, see, like, you know, these differences are really deep and meaningful, but you're like, well, we as a society created those differences. And so people who have more money for resources, those children have more opportunities for cognitive enrichment. And we know things as simple as how many books are in a household correlates with reading ability. And so I think we have to be very sensitive to Matthew effects and how society and inequality can actually create those conditions.
选举。心理学中有一种现象叫马太效应，即富者越富，贫者越贫。你确实会发现，当你年轻时，非常小的优势真的可以累积，当你给人们资源时。随着时间的推移，你会看到这些巨大的差异，你会说，看，这些差异是非常深刻和有意义的，但你会觉得，好吧，是我们作为一个社会创造了这些差异。所以那些有更多金钱资源的人，那些孩子有更多的认知丰富机会。我们知道像家里有多少书这样简单的事情都与阅读能力相关。所以我认为我们必须对马太效应以及社会和不平等如何实际上创造这些条件非常敏感。
Do you think that these tests are better done away with altogether, Scott? You know, I think that these tests can be useful for certain people. And for some students who grow up in very impoverished areas and don't have many ways of displaying their intelligence, these tests can be a ticket out for them. There can be a way for them to advance and for others to see, wow, they do have potential. So we have to be careful. We don't throw the baby out with the bathwater. My point is that we can use these tools in various valuable ways while at the same time, not using them to limit potential.
你认为这些测试最好完全废除吗，斯科特？你知道，我认为这些测试对某些人来说是有用的。对于一些在非常贫困地区长大、没有太多展示自己智力途径的学生来说，这些测试可以成为他们走出困境的门票。这可以成为他们进步的一种方式，也可以让其他人看到，哇，他们确实有潜力。所以我们必须小心。我们不能把孩子和洗澡水一起倒掉。我的观点是，我们可以以各种有价值的方式使用这些工具，同时不利用它们来限制潜力。
So Scott, we got hundreds of emails from listeners about our conversation with you. I think one reason for this is that talk about intelligence strikes at something deep in how we think about ourselves. Here's a message we received from listener Leslie. In middle school, she wanted to be in the advanced math and science track, but was placed in regular classes instead. I loved science. I thought I was good at math because of my conviction.
所以斯科特，我们收到了数百封听众关于我们与你对话的邮件。我认为原因之一是，谈论智力触及了我们思考自身方式中非常深刻的东西。这是我们收到的一位听众莱斯利的留言。在初中时，她想进入高级数学和科学轨道，但却被分到了普通班。我热爱科学。因为我的信念，我以为我擅长数学。
my mom eventually called the school to ask specifically why I was not an accelerated math and science. And I guess my math teacher, who by that point had worked with me for some time, told my mom that I was actually a B student. And the reason why I was getting A's is because I did all my homework, and I participated in class. and that's what brought my grade up. And when I heard that, I was devastated. And it really stuck with me and became part of my identity.
我妈妈最终打电话给学校，专门询问为什么我没有进入加速数学和科学班。我想我的数学老师，那时已经和我共事了一段时间，告诉妈妈我其实是个B等生。我之所以能拿A，是因为我完成了所有的家庭作业，并且在课堂上积极参与。这就是提高我成绩的原因。当我听到这个消息时，我崩溃了。它真的深深印在我的脑海里，成为了我身份的一部分。
That I am not smart. I'm a hard worker. And that there's this difference between being smart and being hardworking. Scott, what are your thoughts on Leslie's story? So I think the idea of a gifted underachiever is incorrect. I don't think there's any such thing. Because if you've gifted underachievers, that means you have unguisted overachievers who just got there through sheer hard work, I guess, is the idea.
那就是我不聪明。我是一个努力工作的人。聪明和努力工作之间存在这种差异。斯科特，你对莱斯利的故事有什么看法？所以我认为天才成绩不佳者的概念是不正确的。我不认为有这样的事情。因为如果你有天才成绩不佳者，那就意味着你有非天才的过度成就者，他们只是通过纯粹的努力工作才达到那个水平，我想这是这个概念。
I think what we need to recognize is that if you show and apply whatever attributes to solve something, you've brought your intelligence to the table to solve that thing. I think it is insulting and demeaning to a human to kind of try to explain it away by something else. While at the same time, I think that it's a great thing to be a hard worker as well. So we should still pat ourselves in the back for working hard. But I hope my point was made. I'm struck by some of the research findings that ask people what makes someone smart. And I've heard that in the United States, people tend to point to ability and intelligence, natural abilities.
我认为我们需要认识到，如果你展示并应用任何属性来解决问题，你就已经运用了你的智力来解决那个问题。我认为试图用其他东西来解释它，对一个人来说是侮辱和贬低。同时，我认为努力工作也是一件伟大的事情。所以我们仍然应该为努力工作而自我鼓励。但我希望我的观点已经表达清楚了。我被一些研究发现所震撼，这些研究询问人们是什么让一个人变得聪明。我听说在美国，人们倾向于指出能力和智力，即天赋。
In many Asian countries, people point to hard work and drive as the central factors behind success. And I find it so interesting that intelligence itself can be understood so differently in different places. Yeah, and maybe there are cultures where hard work is more valued than intelligence, so that telling a student, maybe the reverse would happen in a different culture, but you tell a student, you're just smart, you didn't work hard. and how to upset them. So a lot of it comes down to what do we value in our culture, yeah, overvalue perhaps. Yeah. In addition to hearing from listeners who struggled with standardized testing,
在许多亚洲国家，人们指出努力工作和动力是成功的核心因素。我发现智力本身在不同地方可以被如此不同地理解，这非常有趣。是的，也许有些文化中努力工作比智力更受重视，所以告诉一个学生，也许在不同的文化中情况会相反，但你告诉一个学生，你只是聪明，你没有努力工作，这会让他们感到不安。所以很大程度上归结为我们在文化中重视什么，是的，也许是过度重视。是的。除了听到那些在标准化考试中挣扎的听众的声音外，
we also heard from those who did well on these tests, but then came to feel unhappy about it. Here is listener Barbara, followed by listener Matt. How much research has been done on the opposite problem of the damage done to children who are told at an early age that they are extremely gifted. That was my case. I did well at Tess,
我们也听到了那些在这些测试中表现良好，但后来感到不快乐的人的声音。这是听众芭芭拉，接下来是听众马特。关于那些在很小的时候就被告知自己非常有天赋的孩子所受到的伤害，这种相反的问题做了多少研究？那是我的情况。我在测试中表现良好，
and I excelled in school. And I think the impact on me has been largely negative because family and friends and teachers and coaches perceived me as being exceptionally gifted. They expected that I should be able to achieve anything I wanted to, and when I didn't, I was accused of not trying or of being lazy. And I worked hard to meet expectations
我在学校里表现优异。我认为这对我的影响在很大程度上是负面的，因为家人、朋友、老师和教练都认为我非常有天赋。他们期望我应该能够实现我想要的任何事情，而当我没有做到时，我被指责为没有努力或懒惰。我努力工作以达到期望，
until it very nearly killed me in my later high school years. Because I had a high IQ, I was able to get into large positions of responsibility at work, but frequently didn't have the emotional or social intelligence to stay in those positions. This has resulted in me moving forward.
直到它在高中后期几乎要了我的命。因为我智商高，我能够在工作中获得重要的责任职位，但往往没有情感或社交智力来保持这些职位。这导致我不断前进。
45 or 50 times, you know, my 63-year-old life. But anyway, I was just interested in whether or not that's something that's been examined about how, when you're considered smart, you know, the downsides of that and how that might affect the rest of your life. What do you think of Barbara's and Matt's perspective, Scott? There's this idea because you're gifted, you're expected to act a certain way and achieve a certain outcome in life. And that's a big problem with equating giftedness with achievement potential, as opposed to just treating it as, well, these students have advanced needs or have certain needs
在我63岁的人生中，搬了45或50次家。但无论如何，我只是想知道，关于当你被认为聪明时，这种负面影响以及它如何影响你的余生，是否有人研究过。你如何看待芭芭拉和马特的观点，斯科特？有一种观点认为，因为你有天赋，你就应该以某种方式行事并取得某种生活成果。将天赋与成就潜力等同起来是一个大问题，而不是仅仅把它当作，好吧，这些学生有高级需求或有某些需求，
in their school system that are valuable needs. And, you know, that makes a lot of sense. But signaling to the child that you expect, you know, them to act a certain way is setting them up absolutely for this psyche, you know, where they're a failure in life if they didn't achieve a certain set of expectation. And you see a lot of these young kids who show prowess or, you know, like the prodigies and they get paraded around, you know, on different talk shows and TV shows and, you know, look what they can do. And also you see a lot of unevenness among children who show, you know, these kind of advanced skills, I should say, what you see is a lot of unevenness.
在他们的学校系统中，这些是有价值的需求。而且，你知道，这很有道理。但是向孩子发出信号，期望他们以某种方式行事，绝对是在为这种心理设置陷阱，你知道，如果他们没有达到某种期望，他们就是生活中的失败者。你会看到很多这些表现出天赋的年轻人，或者，你知道，像神童一样，他们被带到不同的脱口秀和电视节目中，你知道，看看他们能做什么。而且你也会看到在表现出这些高级技能的孩子中有很多不平衡，我应该说，你看到的是很多不平衡。
You'll see that their social, emotional development, could be lagging two standard deviations behind their intellectual, you know, advancement. And, you know, just recognizing the huge unevenness, you can see among a lot of these children who we put the label gifted on is so, so important. When we come back, refusing to let your label become,
你会发现他们的社会情感发展可能比他们的智力进步落后两个标准差。而且，你知道，仅仅认识到我们在很多这些孩子身上贴上天才标签时所能看到的巨大不平衡，是非常非常重要的。当我们回来时，拒绝让你的标签成为，
your destiny. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Scott Barry Kaufman is a psychologist at Columbia University. He is the author of the book, Rise Above, Overcome a Victim Mindset, Empower Yourself, and Realize Your Full Potential. We're talking with Scott today about intelligence, how we measure it and the effects that IQ tests have on us. Scott, we heard from a listener named Gigi who said that she got a good score on an IQ test and was labeled smart, Gigi's brother, on the other hand, did not score well. His initial scores came back in the low 70s,
你的命运。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。斯科特·巴里·考夫曼是哥伦比亚大学的心理学家。他是《超越：克服受害者心态，赋予自己力量，实现全部潜能》一书的作者。今天我们和斯科特谈论智力，我们如何衡量它，以及智商测试对我们的影响。斯科特，我们收到了一位名叫吉吉的听众的来信，她说她在智商测试中获得了高分，并被贴上了聪明的标签，而吉吉的兄弟，另一方面，分数并不高。他最初的分数在70分左右，
and he spent his entire academic career in a special education track, and it was really kind of a hard life for him. Like he fell between a lot of cracks and didn't quite have a group, and the services available to him were sometimes limited. but then he took another IQ test in his late 30s, and he scored below 70, which is the threshold for intellectual disability. And after he got that score, all kinds of services and opportunities opened for him that he didn't have before. And honestly, his life changed so much for the better, just over a couple IQ points. And I just wanted to share that with you guys, like some of it's
他整个学术生涯都在特殊教育轨道上度过，对他来说这确实是一种艰难的生活。他落入了很多裂缝中，没有一个群体，他能得到的服务有时也很有限。但后来他在30多岁时又参加了一次智商测试，分数低于70，这是智力残疾的门槛。在他得到那个分数后，各种服务和机会向他敞开，这是他以前没有的。老实说，他的生活变得好多了，仅仅是因为几个智商点。我只是想和你们分享这一点，就像其中一些是
kind of arbitrary, but it can have these huge impacts on people's lives. And I, I'm curious to hear what you guys think. So this is a very important question, Scott. A central issue we've been grappling with is that IQ tests try to turn this very amorphous thing called intelligence into one simple score. You're making the case that this one score is often an oversimplification. But when you start using test scores to screen people, whether that's for giftedness or for disability, you're going to have people on the cusp who could easily fall into one of two categories. And as Gigi says about her brother, different tests can produce different results.
某种程度上是武断的，但它会对人们的生活产生巨大的影响。我很好奇你们怎么看。所以这是一个非常重要的问题，斯科特。我们一直在努力解决的一个核心问题是，智商测试试图将这种被称为智力的非常无定形的东西变成一个简单的分数。你认为这个分数往往是一种过度简化。但当你开始使用测试分数来筛选人时，无论是为了天赋还是残疾，你都会有处于临界点的人，他们很容易落入两个类别中的任何一个。正如吉吉所说，关于她的兄弟，不同的测试可以产生不同的结果。
with dramatically different consequences. Yeah, it's true. Depending on what test you give someone, you might find a different score. And we do live in a system where, unfortunately, these test scores are required in order to get the resources that are important.
并带来截然不同的后果。是的，这是真的。根据你给某人做的测试，你可能会发现不同的分数。我们确实生活在一个系统中，不幸的是，这些测试分数是获得重要资源所必需的。
I've actually argued that people within the IQ band of 70 to 85 really fall between the cracks in a lot of ways because their IQ score is not low enough to get special resource, It's not high enough for gifted education. And a lot of people within that IQ ban could probably benefit from some extra resources, not always, but they probably could. But my argument is intimately tied to my dream of changing policy and having a world where you don't need a label in order to get the resources that showing the need by itself is enough to get the resources.
我实际上主张，智商在70到85之间的人在很多方面确实落入了裂缝，因为他们的智商分数不够低，无法获得特殊资源，也不够高，无法获得天才教育。在这个智商区间内的许多人可能确实能从一些额外资源中受益，不总是，但他们可能可以。但我的论点与我改变政策的梦想紧密相连，拥有一个不需要标签就能获得资源的世界，仅仅展示需求本身就足以获得资源。
Hmm. How would you run such a system, Scott? I'm trying to figure out in terms of resources that you might assign to people who might, you could say, have disabilities of some kind. Wouldn't you need to have a cutoff at some point? And isn't that what these scores are providing? Well, one avenue, which I think is interesting to think about, is a school system where everyone doesn't go through the same, is not expected to go through the same rate in every class. and that you're somehow behind, you know, everyone else if, like, you're not doing well across the board. One idea is this idea that people might use acceleration in one class but not another, or the whole grade-based system might want to be rethought in a lot of thoughtful ways. Of course, there's a benefit of having some more aged people. But just the notion that the process that everyone is on is it looks very deep. different from one student to the next.
嗯。你会如何运行这样一个系统，斯科特？我正在尝试弄清楚你可能会分配给那些你可以说有某种残疾的人的资源。难道你不需要在某个点设置一个截止线吗？这不正是这些分数所提供的吗？嗯，一个我认为值得思考的途径是，一个学校系统，每个人都不经历相同的，不期望在每门课上都经历相同的速度。如果你在各方面表现不佳，你就会在某种程度上落后于其他人。一个想法是，人们可能会在一门课上使用加速，但在另一门课上不使用，或者整个基于年级的系统可能需要在很多深思熟虑的方式上被重新思考。当然，有一些年龄相近的人是有好处的。但仅仅是每个人所处的进程看起来与下一个学生非常不同的概念。
If you buy the idea, Scott, that these tests are measuring only a narrow slice of human ability, is there a way to design a test that in fact captures all of us? What a profound question. I mean, I've attempted to create tests that measure a wider swath of human potential. You know, at self-actualizationtest.com, you can see all a bunch of tests I've developed and designed and scientifically validated, such as... a self-actualization test would love to see that administered in K-12. It shows a much greater multitude of ways in which people can have their own paths, unique paths to self-actualization.
如果你相信斯科特，这些测试只衡量了人类能力的一小部分，有没有办法设计一个实际上能捕捉到我们所有人的测试？这是一个多么深刻的问题。我的意思是，我尝试过创建衡量更广泛人类潜力的测试。你知道，在self-actualizationtest.com上，你可以看到我开发、设计并经过科学验证的一系列测试，例如……一个自我实现测试，我很乐意看到它在K-12中实施。它展示了人们可以拥有自己的道路、独特的自我实现道路的更多方式。
I don't think any test could measure a whole person, but I think we can do a lot better than IQ tests. I've often noticed, Scott, that the older I get, that many jobs are less about intelligence and more about drive. If I had to hire someone and I was picking between someone with a high IQ score and someone who was very driven, I think I would go with the more driven person every time. We received a story from a listener named Pavel about his journey involving IQ tests and hard work. I went to a very small grade school where I was only one of 16 in my grade. I had what was now well known to be dyslexia. This contributed to consistent D's in spelling, reading, writing, and sometimes even math. While the school did not have a
我不认为任何测试都能衡量一个完整的人，但我认为我们可以比智商测试做得更好。我经常注意到，斯科特，我越老，就越发现许多工作与其说是关于智力，不如说是关于动力。如果我必须雇佣某人，并且我在一个智商高的人和一个非常有动力的人之间做选择，我想我每次都会选择那个更有动力的人。我们收到了一位名叫帕维尔的听众关于他涉及智商测试和努力工作的旅程的故事。我上了一所非常小的学校，我所在的年级只有16个人。我有现在众所周知的阅读障碍。这导致我在拼写、阅读、写作方面一直得D，有时甚至在数学上也得D。虽然学校没有
psychologist, they did have a slow learner's track, where I found myself from grades three through five. By fifth grade, I remember feeling out of place in the track, so I asked my father if he could advocate for me to be moved into the regular track. Instead of obliging me, my dad told me, this would be something that I would need to show my teachers, not tell them. So every night he made me read my homework into a tape recorder, and then transcribe what I heard. with special emphasis to correct any transpositions. By the sixth grade, a very kind science teacher, had me move into the regular track.
心理学家，但他们确实有一个慢学习者轨道，我从三年级到五年级都在那里。到了五年级，我记得在那个轨道上感到格格不入，所以我问我父亲他是否能为我争取转入普通轨道。我父亲没有答应我，而是告诉我，这将是我需要向老师展示的事情，而不是告诉他们。所以每天晚上他都让我把家庭作业读进录音机，然后把我听到的转录下来。特别强调纠正任何转置错误。到了六年级，一位非常善良的科学老师让我转入了普通轨道。
Now armed with the tape recorder, which I ended up using all the way through medical school. I started doing relatively well in school. I also leaned into my auditory learning style, and it probably contributed to my choice of the listening specialty of psychiatry. So, Scott, that is such an inspiring story. What do you make of Powell's account?
现在有了录音机，我一直用到医学院毕业。我开始在学校里表现得相对较好。我也倾向于我的听觉学习风格，这可能促成了我选择精神病学这个听觉专业。所以，斯科特，那真是一个鼓舞人心的故事。你如何看待鲍威尔的叙述？
No, I think one thing that illustrates is that, While the idea of learning styles has been discredited in the field of educational psychology, if you think of in terms of visual learning or auditory learning, kinesthetic learning, the research actually does show that learning styles is not very predictive. Just focusing on a singular way of learning doesn't seem to be the magic ticket to learning. I think this illustrates the fact that giving more avenues and more opportunities to learn something through multiple ways of getting at it can be hugely beneficial to a student who may be limited in a particular way of learning something.
不，我认为有一件事说明了，虽然学习风格的概念在教育心理学领域已经被否定了，如果你从视觉学习或听觉学习、动觉学习的角度来思考，研究实际上确实表明学习风格并不是很具有预测性。仅仅专注于一种单一的学习方式似乎并不是学习的魔法门票。我认为这说明了一个事实，即提供更多通过多种方式获取知识的途径和机会，对于一个在特定学习方式上可能受到限制的学生来说，可能非常有益。
You know, for all students, increasing the opportunities for different ways of encoding the same stimuli, whether it's note-taking, whether it's asking questions, seeing the teacher after class and getting that kind of reinforcement. The more reinforcement, the better. So we should be giving those enrichment opportunities across as many modalities as possible to all students. It's going to benefit learning for all students. We heard from many listeners who are diagnosed with dyslexia or ADHD or other learning differences at various points in their education. You mentioned to me that you had an auditory processing issue as a young student.
你知道，对于所有学生，增加通过不同方式编码相同刺激的机会，无论是记笔记，还是提问，课后见老师并获得那种强化。强化越多越好。所以我们应该为所有学生提供尽可能多的模态的丰富机会。这将有利于所有学生的学习。我们听到了许多在教育的各个阶段被诊断出患有阅读障碍或多动症或其他学习差异的听众的声音。你曾向我提到，你年轻时有听觉处理问题。
What do you think our educational system should do to support students with these sorts of challenges who may be labeled not gifted? That's the question, because school systems are not designed to support neurodivergent individuals. And that is like my life's mission is to figure out ways in which not just the school system, but organizational structure. Society can be more welcoming and destigmatize and in a way normalize the fact that we're all freaking weird. You know, like we're all are. And yet we're all expected to be the same. And you go down the line, there are very specific needs that all these different forms of neurodivergency take, where there could be custom-tailored, individualized self-actualization plans that really build on the strengths that a lot of these kids have,
你认为我们的教育系统应该做些什么来支持这些可能被贴上“非天才”标签的、有这类挑战的学生？这就是问题所在，因为学校系统不是为了支持神经多样性个体而设计的。这就像我的人生使命，去找出不仅是学校系统，还有组织结构的方法。社会可以更加热情，去污名化，并在某种程度上正常化我们都是怪胎的事实。你知道，就像我们所有人都是。然而我们都被期望是一样的。你顺着这条线走下去，所有这些不同形式的神经多样性都有非常具体的需求，可以有定制的、个性化的自我实现计划，真正建立在这些孩子拥有的许多优势之上，
as opposed to just focusing on their weaknesses. That would be the big one. You take ADHD, you know, there's rich imagination there. There's rich creativity that is being just squelched because you're forcing them to focus on a boring lecture which drives them, you know, their executive functioning crazy. You know, it's really difficult. It's difficult. If you want to take dyslexia, for instance, a lot of kids with dyslexia are going to be great at business.
而不是仅仅关注他们的弱点。那将是重要的一点。你以多动症为例，你知道，那里有丰富的想象力。有丰富的创造力，仅仅因为你强迫他们专注于一个无聊的讲座而被扼杀，这让他们，你知道，他们的执行功能发疯。你知道，这真的很困难。这很困难。如果你以阅读障碍为例，很多有阅读障碍的孩子在商业方面会很棒。
You know, if you give them opportunities to sell things to other students or to create a business, figure out a business plan to go out there and act and move and not be forced to just. just read, you know, you'll see that they have amazing capacities there. Autism, you know, if you want to look at autism, you can say, well, wow, if you listen to their special interest area, if you listen, if you really ask them, you know, what are you passionate about? What is that? You know, and listen to them and lead with that as opposed to forcing them to be interested in things that are, you know, you'll see so much greater potential than you see. So there's a lot there. There's a common thread in all of the examples you just gave me, Scott, and that's,
你知道，如果你给他们机会向其他学生推销东西或创建一个企业，想出一个商业计划去外面行动和移动，而不是被迫仅仅阅读，你知道，你会看到他们在那里有惊人的能力。自闭症，你知道，如果你想看看自闭症，你可以说，哇，如果你听他们的特殊兴趣领域，如果你听，如果你真的问他们，你知道，你对什么充满热情？那是什么？你知道，并倾听他们，并以此为引导，而不是强迫他们对那些，你知道，你会看到比你看到的更大的潜力。所以那里有很多东西。你刚才给我的所有例子中都有一个共同点，斯科特，那就是，
the system is trying to put everyone through the same, you know, round hole. And some of us are round pegs, and we go through the hole really easily, and some of us are square pegs, and we don't. And you're saying, let's build some more square holes. I agree with that a thousand percent. And I really agree that that is a major problem we have in our education system. It's not designed for difference. It's designed. for sameness in a way. And in some ways, that's a very industrial model of education, right? Because we want widgets, and we want all of the things to go through the assembly line in the
系统试图把每个人都塞进同一个，你知道，圆孔里。我们中的一些人是圆钉，我们很容易穿过那个孔，而我们中的一些人是方钉，我们穿不过去。而你说，让我们多造几个方孔。我百分之千同意这一点。而且我非常同意这是我们教育系统中的一个主要问题。它不是为差异而设计的。它在某种程度上是为相同而设计的。在某些方面，这是一种非常工业化的教育模式，对吧？因为我们想要小部件，我们想要所有的东西都以同样的方式通过装配线，
same way, as opposed to saying, well, you're dealing with human beings, you're not dealing with widgets. And so maybe the assembly line has to adapt itself to the people instead of the other way around. That's right. And also acknowledging there's many paths to greatness. And that one insight can revolutionize education if we took it seriously. Hmm. We heard from some listeners who are really struggling with their perceptions of their own intelligence and feelings of self-worth.
而不是说，好吧，你是在处理人类，你不是在处理小部件。所以也许装配线必须适应人，而不是反过来。没错。而且还要承认通往伟大的道路有很多条。如果我们认真对待，那一个洞察力就能彻底改变教育。嗯。我们听到了一些听众的声音，他们真的在与对自己智力的看法和自我价值感作斗争。
Here's a message we received from a listener named Jennifer. I related to a lot of what Scott was mentioning throughout the podcast about just having moments where you are like singled out and you're like, oh my gosh, like, am I the dumbest person in the world? and I guess I sometimes get so caught up in the belief that I am not good enough, not smart enough, and I often forget about the moments where I am told I'm shown otherwise. And I guess my question to Scott would be, what, how do you get yourself to, I guess, believe more about not getting so hung up on the negative, but staying on the positive. I think it's something that I really struggle with. Yeah, I guess what are helpful ways to make me remind myself that I am smart enough?
这是我们收到的一位名叫詹妮弗的听众的留言。我与斯科特在整个播客中提到的很多内容产生了共鸣，关于仅仅是有时被挑出来，你会想，天哪，我是世界上最笨的人吗？我想我有时太沉迷于我不够好、不够聪明的信念中，我经常忘记那些我被告知、被证明并非如此的时刻。我想我问斯科特的问题是，什么，你如何让自己，我想，更多地相信不要在消极的事情上纠结，而是保持积极。我想这确实是我非常挣扎的事情。是的，我想有什么有用的方法能让我提醒自己我足够聪明？
So you can hear how Jennifer has struggled with this question, Scott. My heart really goes out to her. What advice would you have for listeners like Jennifer? Yeah, well, first I want to say relatable. You know, Jennifer's not alone, and it's such a pervasive, common feeling in question. But I think for a lot of people who feel things very deeply and are really caring, compassionate humans, they have a lot of trouble with something I call self-anchoring. So they'll constantly be scanning others for approval,
所以你可以听到詹妮弗是如何在这个问题上挣扎的，斯科特。我的心真的与她同在。你对像詹妮弗这样的听众有什么建议？是的，首先我想说，这很有共鸣。你知道，詹妮弗并不孤单，这是一个非常普遍、常见的感觉和问题。但我认为对于许多感受非常深刻、非常关心、富有同情心的人来说，他们在某种我称之为“自我锚定”的事情上遇到了很多麻烦。所以他们会不断地扫描他人以寻求认可，
and they won't ever feel like they can feel confident in themselves or feel worthy, unless someone else deems that they're allowed to feel worthy. And I think that self-anchoring is a process. It takes a lot of work, but it's a skill set. I have come such a long way, and I still have a long way to go, my friend. But when I think about how I used to be and how I would never have any sense of my own self, I was always just looking at how other people were judging me, and I would internalize that.
除非别人认为他们有资格感到有价值，否则他们永远不会觉得他们可以对自己感到自信或感到有价值。我认为自我锚定是一个过程。这需要很多努力，但它是一套技能。我已经走了很长一段路，但我还有很长的路要走，我的朋友。但当我想到我过去的样子，以及我如何永远不会有任何自我意识时，我总是只是看着别人如何评判我，我会内化这一点。
I realized that life doesn't have to be that way. I realize that you can lead with yourself. You don't have to wait for the world to tell you who you are to act or be a certain way. You can learn self-anchoring and self-leadership skills. Can you give me a couple of aspects of the self-anchoring process, Scott, things that you did yourself to help you anchor yourself rather than look to others to give you a sense of your self-worth? Yeah, it's all about leading with your passions, with your values, with the things that you know are true and valid about yourself. The earliest example of that is when I took myself out of special education, I chose myself. At that moment, I was in a position where the school system was telling me I was a certain way.
我意识到生活不必那样。我意识到你可以以自己为先。你不必等待世界告诉你你是谁来行动或以某种方式行事。你可以学习自我锚定和自我领导技能。你能给我几个自我锚定过程的方面吗，斯科特，你为了帮助自己锚定自己而不是寻求他人给你自我价值感而做的事情？是的，这完全是关于以你的激情、你的价值观、你知道关于你自己是真实和有效的事情为先。最早的例子就是当我把自己从特殊教育中带出来时，我选择了自己。在那一刻，我处于一个学校系统告诉我我是某种样子的位置。
And I was like, you know what? I'm going to change the script. I'm going to tell the school system that I can handle it. Give me a chance. I'd like to share one more listener story with you, Scott. This one comes to a man named Sean. From an early age, Sean was told that he was bad at math, but he did not allow that to deter him. As I went through school, I was repeatedly reminded that I was not good at math.
我说，你知道吗？我要改变剧本。我要告诉学校系统我能应付。给我一个机会。我想再和你分享一个听众的故事，斯科特。这个故事来自一个叫肖恩的人。从很小的时候起，肖恩就被告知他不擅长数学，但他没有让这阻止他。当我上学时，我被反复提醒我不擅长数学。
I ultimately barely graduated high school by taking what was called business, math at the time, simply balancing your budget and keeping a checkbook. But it wasn't until my late 20s when I decided to go back to college and had to take a placement exam. I tested into what was called Math E, which was math essentials. It was self-paced learning and I had to relearn multiplication, subtraction, division, decimals, you know, percentages. It was very, very basic stuff. But after that, I got into my first algebra class and quickly rose to the top of it. Ultimately, I went on to get a degree in economics with a minor in accounting. And for the rest of my school career, absolutely loved math, numbers, puzzles, and problem solving,
我最终勉强高中毕业，通过参加当时所谓的商业数学，仅仅是平衡你的预算和记账。但直到我20多岁时，我决定回到大学并不得不参加分班考试。我被分到了所谓的数学E，也就是数学基础。那是自定进度的学习，我不得不重新学习乘法、减法、除法、小数，你知道，百分比。那是非常非常基础的东西。但在那之后，我进入了我的第一门代数课，并迅速升至顶峰。最终，我继续获得了经济学学位，辅修会计。在剩下的学校生涯中，我绝对热爱数学、数字、谜题和解决问题，
and went on to graduate with honors. And so it's difficult to say that one form of intelligence is better than another, because, like I said, I was told I sucked at math, and now that's what I do for a living, and I do it well. So Scott, Sean's message makes me think about how learning never ends and who we think we are can change over time. I love that. You know, I saw Larry David give a talk recently.
并以优异成绩毕业。所以很难说一种智力比另一种更好，因为，就像我说的，我被告知我数学很烂，而现在这就是我谋生的手段，而且我做得很好。所以斯科特，肖恩的信息让我想到了学习永无止境，以及我们认为我们是谁可以随着时间而改变。我喜欢那个。你知道，我最近看到拉里·大卫做了一个演讲。
He said, I went like 25, 30 years trying to do stand-up, and I sucked. He said, people booed me off stage. She's like, I thought I had no talents. I thought like my life was like over, you know, And then, you know, him and Seinfeld were like, let's start a TV show. He realized that, wow, like, this was my very specific niche that, like, I can actually be great and I can actually flourish. And I just, I think we have to really remember that life is this overarching curve that, you know, we're not defined or limited by who we are or how we're being received in this moment in time. Scott Barry Kaufman is a psychologist at Columbia University.
他说，我花了25、30年试图做单口相声，但我很烂。他说，人们把我嘘下台。她说，我以为我没有天赋。我以为我的生活结束了，你知道，然后，你知道，他和宋飞就像，让我们开始一个电视节目吧。他意识到，哇，这确实是我非常具体的利基，我可以真正变得伟大，我可以真正蓬勃发展。我只是，我认为我们必须真正记住，生活是这条总体的曲线，你知道，我们并没有被我们在这一刻是谁或我们如何被接收所定义或限制。斯科特·巴里·考夫曼是哥伦比亚大学的心理学家。
He's the author of Rise Above, Overcome a Victim Mindset, Empower Yourself, and Realize Your Full Potential. Scott, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you. It was a real pleasure. Always talking to you. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Querell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brains executive editor. If you enjoyed today's conversation,
他是《超越：克服受害者心态，赋予自己力量，实现全部潜能》的作者。斯科特，非常感谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢。这真是一种荣幸。总是和你交谈。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。如果你喜欢今天的对话，
please consider sharing it with your friends and loved ones. Word of mouth recommendations really help to connect more people with the ideas and research that we explore on the show. I'm Shankar Vedantham. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请考虑与你的朋友和亲人分享。口碑推荐真的有助于将更多人与我们在节目中探索的想法和研究联系起来。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。